Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Wir brauchen einen Rapper, der sich gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ausspricht. Dann ist das Ding durch.
Und wir brauchen auf jeden Fall fünf Blockchains.
Netzpolitik Nummer dreihundertundfünfundachtzig vom zehnten März zwanzig einundzwanzig. Hier seid ihr perfekt abgesichert dezentral und international und überhaupt global und
digital und was nicht alles so auf Aal noch endet.
Wir sind hinter sieben Proxis und fünf Blockchain.
So sieht's aus, komplett.
Und QR-Code haben wir auch.
Auf Wunsch.
Und ich kaufe mir gleich Schnaps.
Vielleicht gibt's uns auch bald auf CD.
Ich kann äh ich, ja, für.
Du leidest jetzt schon ein bisschen, ne?
Ich leide. Also diese Sendung wird wirklich.
Jede Sendung leiden wir.
So
Das ist das ist ja halt so unsere unsere private genau, fühl den Ozean, die Weite, lass sie in dich hinein.
Genau.
Tim, hast du Kippen?
Nee, aber ich habe noch Tabletten.
Okay. So, dann wollen wir mal schauen, ob wir hier durch die Nummer durchkommen.
Ja, heute geht's viel um äh Corona. Da haben wir ja letzte Mal auch schon drüber gesprochen. Ja, es geht doch immer um Corona, oder?
Weißt du eigentlich da schon wieder, habe ich auch letztens gelesen. Corona.
Da
Ja, das ist so ein Hype irgendwie. Das ist ach, weißt du, wie das ist mit diesen Hypes, das hält sich zehn Jahre und dann redet wieder keiner drüber.
Ja, aber weißt du auch, mit den Halbstühlen, das kommt auch alles wieder, ne?
Das stimmt allerdings, manche halten sich auch wirklich ziemlich lange. Da haben wir auf jeden Fall auch noch ein Thema.
Oje.
Fangen wir erstmal ein bisschen mit Feedback an. Wir hatten ja letzte Mal und Spoiler, Spoiler, weil wir auch dieses Mal wieder äh das Thema mit dem,
Impfausweisen, beziehungsweise sehr generellen Frage, wie es sich denn jetzt eigentlich verhält mit,
den Grundrechten, die man hat und einschränkt und ob das Aufheben dieser Einschränkungen selbst wiederum ein Privileg darstellt oder nicht eher die Wiederherstellung des Normalzustands.
Und das ja, war ja auch bei uns in gewisser Hinsicht schon so eine philosophische äh Frage und würde gar nicht mal behaupten, dass wir da,
unbedingt jetzt äh auf einen Nenner gekommen sind, so ohne weiteres, weil's eben auch nicht einfach zu beantworten ist.
Und so ein bisschen stellvertretend für für diese beiden Sichtweisen oder zumindest zwei mögliche Interpretationen. Wollen wir mal ein paar Kommentare hier vorlesen, die so,
das ganz, ganz gut wiedergeben, wie das bei euch so angekommen ist. Da schreibt uns zu dies einmal User Union.
Ich sehe es auch mit Missbehagen, wenn Selbstverständlichkeiten als Privilegien bezeichnet werden. Sicher, man kann einen Vergleich anstellen. Die einen dürfen, die anderen dürfen nicht, also sind die, die dürfen privilegiert.
Dass jemand im hohen Alter oder mit gesundheitlichen Risiken, Neumonal, Diabetes, weiß der Geier, dann die Möglichkeit hatte, sich impfen zu lassen und ich armer Mittelalter gesunder,
die Möglichkeit nicht hatte und deswegen nicht zu den ins Café oder zu einer privaten Feier mit mehr als zwei Personen aus fünf Haushalten. Das soll mich auf die Barrikaden treiben und den Zusammenbruch der Zivilgesellschaft bewirken,
Von meiner Seite nicht. Ja, das ist ärgerlich, dies und das nicht zu dürfen, aber was habe ich davon, wenn mal vereinfacht gesagt, Senioren zum vereinzelten Stubenhocken gezwungen werden?
Ich kann sogar soweit denken, dass vielleicht die geimpften Senioren die Restaurants am Leben erhalten, die ich dann erst zwei oder vier Monate später besuchen kann. Und es stimmt auch nicht ganz,
Dass man es selbst nicht in der Hand hat und ob man geimpft ist oder nicht,
als Impfverweigerer freiwillig drauf verzichten und sitzt dann zurecht als einer der wenigen seiner Altersgehorte alleine zu Hause. Ich würde ja sagen, dass das eine alte kommunistische Utopie ist, dass es allen gleich schlecht gehen muss, wenn ich euch im Verdacht hätte, Kommunisten zu sein.
Wieso hat sie uns nicht im Vertrag Kommunisten zu sein?
Weiß gar nicht, ob wir jetzt so konkret so gemeint sind, sondern so alle, ne. Sind ja eigentlich alles Kommunisten irgendwo.
Äh dann fügt er noch an oder sie einen Punkt, der mir bei der Frage wie so eine Prüfung aussehen soll, ob man wahrscheinlich immun ist, aufgefallen ist. Man muss doch heute auf höchstwackeliger Datenbasis nichts sagen
bis wann man als wahrscheinlich sicher gelten soll, es gilt auch festzuhalten, wenn man,
Entschuldigung, wann man womit geimpft wurde beziehungsweise welche Virenvariante man überlebt hat,
man dann in zwei Jahren sieht, dass ein vermuteter, spezieller Schutz fragil wird, könnte man dann, wenn es soweit ist, die Verbote Pflichten für die Betroffenen wieder enger ziehen.
Und das Dokument muss mit Einschränkungen auch nicht hundert Prozent fälschungssicher sein, nicht jeder hat die kriminelle Energie, sowas zu fälschen. Allerdings sollte es Strafen für das Fälschen geben, insbesondere, wenn man das kommerziell für Dritte und im großen Stil betreibt.
Ja gut, das geht auch eigentlich für den heutigen Impfpass. Der ist definitiv nicht zu hundert Prozent hundert Prozent fälschungssicher,
und ja klar, mit der kriminellen Energie ist halt immer die Frage, was da dran hängt, ne. Gut, aber ohne das groß diskutieren zu wollen oder möchtest du da noch kurz das.
Weiter ein wichtiger Punkt angesprochen wird. Das war tatsächlich etwas, was in der letzten Sendung mir,
auch aufgefallen ist, dass da halt dieses diese also bei der Frage Impfpass wird häufig das Argument angebracht, wir wissen doch noch gar nicht, ob eine Impfung nicht ansteckend macht oder vor allem, wie lange die anhält,
aber das ist auch das, was hier User eben sagt. Das ist unerheblich, weil du einfach nur das Impfdatum und den Impfstoff einträgst,
und ob du das dann fünf oder zehn äh Wochen später noch akzeptierst. Ähm kannst du ja dann davon abhängig machen, was da drin steht und wie zu dem Zeitpunkt der Kenntnisstand ist, ne. Also du du schreibst ja quasi nicht in den Impfausweis,
geimpft bist so und so, sondern du schreibst rein, wurde geimpft arm. Also das war tatsächlich ein leichter Denkfehler in der letzten Sendung, der da
Zumindest wiederholt wurde bei der in der öffentlichen Debatte auch häufiger waren.
Gut, dann vielleicht eine etwas andere Perspektive von Sandra atmen.
Es ist ganz interessant, vor gar nicht allzu langer Zeit, habe ich das ähnlich wie Thomas und Tim und so weiter gesehen, Grundrechte sind keine Privilegien, sondern eben Rechte. Die kann man mir einschränken, wenn nötig, aber sobald der Grund wegfällt, muss auch die Einschränkung wegfallen.
Inzwischen sehe ich das aber auch eher wie Lino ist erstens, wenn andere Leute ihre Grundrechte wieder wahrnehmen dürfen und ich nicht, ist das eine Privilegierung und in der Praxis sogar eine ziemlich extreme. Und das,
extrem gesellschaftlichen Sprengstoff aus diversen Gründen. Erstens haben wir das Problem, dass bereits die Impfpriorisierung relativ willkürlich ist.
Menschen, achtzig plus sind Gruppe eins, während Menschen mit schweren Vorerkrankungen, Pauschalen Gruppe zwei und später eingestuft wurden, selbst wenn Todesrisiko mit einem entsprechenden Krankheitsbild statistisch höher ist als mit achtzig Jahren.
Medizinstudenten im praktischen Jahr werden nicht geimpft, obwohl sie exakt neben dem geimpften Arzt stehen und exakt
gleiche machen. Pflegepersonal für bestimmte Hochrisikogruppen wird geimpft. Die eigenen Eltern, die mit dem Kind zusammenleben und nebenbei mindestens dreißig Prozent der täglichen Pflegezeit übernehmen müssen, haben keinen Impfanspruch.
Meine Freundin musste sich jetzt am dritten März mit der ersten Dosis impfen lassen, weil sie in der Corona-Forschung arbeitet
Jetzt ist es aber so, dass sie die gesamte AG zu keinem Zeitung mit infektiösen Material arbeitet und bis auf Weiteres arbeiten wird. Selbst wenn du dir die Proben spritzen würdest, bekämst du nichts, zumindest kein Corona,
Opa achtundsiebzig und seit Monaten Darmkrebs frei,
Erstimpfung dagegen frühestens in der zweiten Märzhälfte. Der nächste Punkt ist, dass es beim Impfpass ja nur um die Impfung geht, aber wie sieht es eigentlich mit Leuten aus, die die Krankheit hinter sich gebracht haben?
Dass es Ende Januar einer Freundin von mir passiert, die arbeitet als Ärztin im Krankenhaus und hat sich dort infiziert und ist deshalb erstmal für sechs Monate geblockt
Mal ganz abgesehen davon, dass sie jetzt mit Mitte zwanzig ein komplett vernarbtes Lungengewebe hat und nicht einmal in den zweiten Stock kommt, ohne fast zu kollabieren.
Stand jetzt heißt das, dass sie frühestens Anfang November mit ihrer Zweitimpfung durch wäre.
Und drittens haben wir das ganz praktische Problem, dass eine solche Regelung zum zum Großteil die treffen wird, die ohnehin mit am meisten von den Alltagseinschränkungen betroffen sind.
Insbesondere junge bis mittelalter Personen, die mit wenig Geld und am besten noch mit Kindern in beengten Wohnverhältnissen leben. Erkläre denen mal, dass die fünfzig plus High Society jetzt wieder in die Deutsche Oper und danach ins Restaurant darf, während sie mit ihren Kindern noch nicht mal ins Kino dürfen.
Ich mache mir da jetzt auch keine Sorgen. Eine Regierung, die alle Jahre wieder verfassungswidrige Gesetze verabschiedet und im Jahr einundzwanzig immer noch Cannabis massiv kriminalisiert, kommt es schon hin, die Einschränkungen erstmal auch für Geimpfte aufrechtzuerhalten, wenn sie es denn will,
Wobei die Argumentation natürlich nur gilt, solange der Impfstoff nur reguliert ist, sobald sich jeder auf Wunsch zeitnah impfen lassen kann, sieht das natürlich ganz anders aus. Da kann ein Imachweis, ein relativ praktisches Mittel sein,
um einen Anreiz zum Impfen zu schaffen.
Würde ich mich ja auch anschließen. Ähm.
Thomas hatte, glaube ich, in der letzten Sendung eigentlich was sehr Wichtiges gesagt, ähm dass ich nochmal wiederholen würde, ne. Es ist nicht der Impfpass, der der Weg aus der äh Pandemie ist, sondern die Impfung,
und die muss halt zügig zugänglich gemacht werden und dann äh würde ich auch ähm,
Sache mit den Impfpässen entspannter sehen. So sieht denn äh sinnvoll implementiert würden, doch dazu später.
Ja, ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, wie sie jetzt von Januar auf November mit sechs Monaten äh kommt. Die Rechnung kann ich nicht so ganz nachvollziehen. Aber äh wir lassen das jetzt hier.
Wir lassen das jetzt hier erstmal so stehen, ähm das mal hier zur Diskussion gebracht.
Das Impfen beginnt.
Beginnt das Impfen? Im November.
Ende Januar, wahrscheinlich deshalb ist sie jetzt sechs Monate gebloggt und dann kann sie essen, dann kann sie ja quasi im nach sechs Monaten erst anfangen zu impfen und dann dauert's und dann Anfang November die Zweitimpfung, die dem auch sei, okay, wir müssen.
Also okay, ich äh ich ich weiß.
In Frage stellen.
Ich weiß jetzt, wie's äh gerechnet ist. Heißt so viel wie im August äh darf dann sozusagen die Erstimpfung machen und bei Asthal sind's ja jetzt drei Monate bis zu zweit Impfung.
Okay, gut.
Okay. So, dann hatten wir noch Feedback zur Sendung davor, äh wo wir das über IT über das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei gesprochen haben.
Das Feedback äh hatten wir gar nicht verwendet, weil wir, ja, so schnell hintereinander released haben. Und zwar hat sich da äh nur Zoom in den Kommentaren gemeldet, ist die Mitarbeiterin,
von der Tabea Rößner. Kurze Erinnerung, ich hatte ja gesagt, dass ich den Eindruck hatte, dass äh insbesondere diese Anhörung halt alle durch waren und das eher so all das.
Schein aufrecht erhalten haben und alle ihren Teil quasi verlesen haben. Ich hatte aber auch gesagt, dass sich das insbesondere der Tabea Rößner nicht zur Last legen kann, weil die ja eingesprungen war
für den Konstantin von Nutzer. Jetzt meldet sich also Miriam Seifert und sagt nochmal, gibt nochmal ein bisschen Kommentar dazu. Kurz zum Kapitel Anhörungsverlauf. Ein Blick,
hinter die Kulissen. Als zuständige wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiterin im Büro von Tabea Rößner, von der Grünen Bundestagsfraktion kann ich bestätigen.
Dass wir hier aktuell alle deutlich hinter der maximalen Belastungsgrenze agieren. Du hast treffend beschrieben, dass wir als kleinste Opposition,
Oppositionsfraktion im Bundestag aktuell komplett von der Bundesregierung gedest werden mit Gesetzesvorhaben
noch schnell vor der Wahl durchgepeitscht werden sollen. Ist ja immer so. Auch wir kriegen Gesetzesentwürfe mit mehreren hundert Seiten oder,
Änderungsanträge oft erst kurz vor knapp auf den Tisch, genau wie ihr
mit den kurzen Fristen für die Stellungnahmen. Zu den absurd kurzen Fristen für die Verbändebeteiligung haben wir uns mit einer kleinen Anfrage nochmal bei der Bundesregierung nachgehakt was das eigentlich soll.
Sie sich nicht schämt.
Du und Frank, ihr konntet euch die Anhörungen zur TKG-Novelle und zum IT-Sicherheitsgesetz aufteilen. Tabea hat an dem Tag,
In beiden Anhörungen, an beiden Anhörungen direkt hintereinander teilgenommen und sich dementsprechend auf beide vorbereiten müssen. Und das, obwohl sie,
aktuell und seit ein paar Wochen krankgeschrieben ist,
Weil die Personaldecke aber in der kleinsten Fraktion dünn ist, zieht sie die Anhörung trotzdem durch. Wir nehmen die halt ernst und nur für den restlichen Kontext, Tabea und ihr Team,
müssen parallel parallel auch noch die Urheberrechtsreform bearbeiten, die gerade ansteht, die TKD-Novelle, die Novelle zum Förderungsgesetz, das Gesetz für faire Verbraucherverträge,
das Gesetz für digitale Dienste und einen großen Schwung weiterer umfangreicher Gesetzesinitiativen. In anderen äh Abgeordneten Büros sieht es natürlich ähnlich aus,
das erklärt vielleicht einiges. Danke für deine äh tolle Stellungnahme und deine pointierten Bemerkungen in der Anhörung. War eine Freude dem zu folgen.
Und äh fände ich jetzt tatsächlich sehr wichtig, das auch nochmal zu zeigen, ne, wie es bei denen aussieht. Ich kenne ja mehrere äh Mitarbeiterinnen
Bundestagsabgeordneten und das ist
insbesondere in dieser Zeit des Jahres echt kein Job, auf den du neidisch bist, ne? Das ist wirklich
ein Knochenjob und das ist auch echt krass, äh das nochmal zu wiederholen hier, dass die ähm Tabea Rößner in beiden Anhörungen waren, ja? Und die TKG-Novelle anhören, die war auf vier Stunden
festgesetzt. Das heißt, die hat da eine ähm sechs Stunden irgendwie in Anhörungen gefristet und entsprechend.
Muss die ja mindestens auf dem inhaltlichen Kenntnisstand sein, ähm wie die Sachverständigen, die da angehört werden. Also das ist schon echt nochmal eine ganz andere Hausnummer.
Ähm dann auch zu der Anhörung hatte, hat Christoph noch gefragt, ist es eigentlich Usus, dass bei sachverständigen Anhörungen nur sachverständiger eingeladen werden, die gegen das vorgeschlagene Gesetz sind? Oder hat die Union niemanden gefunden, der den,
Gesetzesentwurf mit Sachverstand verteidigt. Ja lieber Christoph, letzteres ist der Fall ne, die Sachverständigen sind,
unabhängig. Da wird jetzt auch nicht ausgeknobelt was du dazu sagst. Insofern kauf da,
die das Ausschusssekretariat, die Katze im Sack und auch die jeweiligen Parteien, die die.
Sachverständigen vorschlagen, kaufen eine Katze im Sack. So ist das eben bei Unabhängigkeit, das ist auch gut so. Aber ähm ja, jetzt war das natürlich,
Also sagen wir mal so, der Bitcom, der ja jetzt auch zum Beispiel da vertreten war, ist jetzt als ähm Branchenverband nicht,
unbedingt dafür bekannt, dass er äh bei Gesetzesvorhaben jetzt großartig als Quirulant,
agiert, ne? Und ähm auch bei dem äh Professor für Verwaltungsrecht, Herrn Gerditz, hieß er, glaube ich, ähm.
Ist das jetzt, ne? Du rechnest ja nicht damit, dass die, also, ne, du, du gehst ja irgendwie davon aus, dass sie halbwegs wohlgesonnen wären, ne.
Und ja, ist dann eben
diesmal schief gegangen. Das liegt eher an der Qualität des Gesetzes, aber ich will niemandem sagen, dass die Leute da irgendwie Gefälligkeitsgutachten oder sonst etwas machen würden und das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Sind Sachverständige, die geben Auskünfte
und wenn du halt ein schlechtes Gesetz hast, dann äh kritisieren dir das eben auch. Bei je nachdem, was für Gesetze du hast, hast du dann natürlich auch ähm.
Interessenverbände, Vorsitz äh vor, ne, in den, in den Anhörungen
zum Beispiel, die jetzt grade reguliert werden sollen, ne? Das sagen die auch nicht, dass der Gesetzesvorschlag von besonderer Brillanz ist, wenn ihnen da ähm,
irgendwie was aufs Auge gedrückt werden soll. Das ist zum Beispiel hier der Fall ähm in der Stellungnahme, die ich auch von per Hine ähm,
ja, ein bisschen wiedergegeben hatte zum zur TKG-Novelle. Ähm,
zum äh Telekommunikationsmodernisierungsgesetz, das ist ja auch der kommentierte ja als Vertreter einer betroffenen Branche oder als Vertreter eines äh betroffenen Unternehmens, ne? Und dann ist der natürlich auch,
kritisch.
Aber das ist ja auch der also Sinn der Sache, ne. Also die Idee dieser Anhörung ist, dass äh ja Sachverständige oder Betroffene oder Interessenvertreterinnen sagen, das was da auf, was ihr da auf das Papier geschrieben habt, bedeutet,
Folgendes für unseren Bereich und unsere Perspektiv,
Also von der Idee ist das eine feine Sache, aber wenn das eben dann so auf Kante genäht ist, wie jetzt hier auch ähm Miriam das beschrieben hat, dann,
weißt du eben auch Bescheid.
Ja, dann hatten wir noch reichlich Kommentare. Tim hatte das schon nach der Sendung zu mir gesagt. Dir ist klar, dass die Kommentare voll sein werden mit Lego. Ja, die Kommentare waren voll mit Lego. Ja, es gibt gerade äh kontroversen.
Um das Unternehmen Lego, weil es mal wieder äh eine Reihe äh juristischer Auseinandersetzungen mit äh,
Klemmsteinhändlerinnen führt ähm und äh das ist äh macht macht nicht den sympathischsten Eindruck,
aber ich möchte dass wir auch insbesondere aktuelle Legoprodukte,
nicht äh besonders über den Klee gelobt haben, eher im Gegenteil, Tim spielt nur mit Vierern und Achtern und ich nur mit LEGO Creator oder Technikmodellen. Früher war er sowieso alles besser
und ähm.
Ja und das ist ja auch so, ich meine, mal ehrlich, kann man ja auch nicht von der Hand weisen, Lego ist halt so was wie Tempo irgendwie. Das ist halt die generische Bezeichnung für Baustein.
Ja, weißt du, das sind so.
Das ist richtig und aber genau dagegen müssen also weil das so ist, müssen die quasi ihren Markenanspruch auch aggressiver verteidigen. Ich habe mich da ein bisschen eingelesen. Die gehen also einmal.
Klar, das ist so wie wenn Google nicht möchte, dass man das Wort Google benutzt.
Ja, genau. Und aber das ist der eine Fall und dann gibt's aber noch einen anderen, also der eine ist, wo sie den,
YouTuber Herr der Steine, Abmahn, weil der Lego zu Klemmstein sagt. Und das andere ist, da gibt es einen äh ebenfalls klemm Steinhändler,
der von einem anderen Hersteller die Produkte importiert, ne? Also wenn du jetzt irgendwie.
Ne, das ist der Generalimporteur, so habe ich das verstanden für Deutschland oder ein Importeur für Deutschland von diesen von dieser Art Stein aus China. So und Lego,
hat halt offenbar versucht mit Hilfe des Zolls, den Import der Produkte dieses Herstellers zu verhindern. Leidtragender ist natürlich jetzt dieser Importeur,
der Krempel jetzt irgendwo beim Zoll steht und der Zoll äh vermietet die Lagerfläche zu sportlichen Preisen. Und die Auseinandersetzung wird natürlich irgendwie Ewigkeiten gehen,
das zermalt natürlich dann irgendwie so einen kleinen Importeur, der einfach nur ein paar Steinchen verkaufen möchte, ne. Also das sind das ist alles unappetitlich.
Die Judos, die äh Videos kann man sich mal in Ruhe anschauen, während man ein schönes Lego-Modell baut. Ist ein schönes chinesisches Lego-Modell. Oh nein, jetzt werden wir abgemahnt.
Ich wollte nur noch betonen, dass ich zumindest in dem Moment, wo ich von Legos gesprochen habe, sozusagen, Lego S Ingenieuric Klemmstein gesprochen habe.
Tim, nein, nein, nein, ich will nicht von denen abgemahnt werden. Bitte sag,
Die machen uns fertig, Mann. Kannst du dich mit Lego an an anlegen? Die haben angefangen. Ey, die die kennen keine, die kennen keine ähm die kennen keine Gnade. Die machen uns platt, ey.
Ach, da stelle ich mich Matrix-mäßig hin und sage, kommt doch.
Bleibt kein Tempo, da hast du mehr trocken, wenn uns Lego verklagt.
So sieht's aus.
Okay.
Zurück zu Corona.
Zurück zu zu Themen, wo wir alle wissen, wer der Feind ist.
Richtig schön durchatmen.
Trinke noch mal einen Schluck Schnaps.
Ich bin auch froh, dass hier noch ein Bier habe, so zum Frühstück ist das eigentlich genau das Richtige.
Also.
In den hat Tim ein Rolf hinterlegt. Rolf.
Kennt ihr noch Rolf?
Rolf war mein bester Freund in dem Alter, ne. Nein, Quatsch.
Ja, echt. Na komm. Du hast bestimmt so ein Bravo-Starschnitt oder was gehabt von.
Hintergrund, der Hintergrund von Roy Feier.
Das mit der Wiedervereinigung Deutschlands ähm beziehungsweise der Überführung der äh deutschen Demokratischen Republik in die BRD GmbH, ähm die.
Die die äh die Postleitzahlen neu gewürfelt werden mussten.
Und zwar mit einem W fünf. Es gab nämlich jetzt auf einmal fünfstellige Postleitzahlen. Vorher hattest du vierstellige Postleitzahlen im Westen. Im Osten weiß ich nicht wie äh wie die Possettzeilen da waren. Welche wie viel stell ich würde jetzt schätzen.
Ich glaube, einen W fünf haben sie nicht genommen, weil ist ja auch eine Sechs- und eine Sieben
acht und eine neun vertreten, aber was du meinst, ist halt einfach fünfstellige Postleitzahlen und dafür muss natürlich geworben werden und da hat sich die Post gedacht, da machen wir mal sowas richtig Nettes, so wie die Bahn diesen schicken Maulwurf hat,
Baustellen.
Weil wir auch dafür werben muss, dass die Postleitzahl jetzt fünfstellig sind. So.
Ja
Willst du dafür werben?
Ähm na ja, weil Leute müssen, die natürlich dann auch benutzen. Das heißt, sie müssen da eine gewisse Awareness äh haben und äh sonst ist das dann später sehr teuer. Also es mag durchaus sinnvoll gewesen sein, dass ähm
auch humorvoll zu begleiten. Das ist ihn halt auch halbwegs gelungen und dazu gab's dann
Rolf, so eine Art Comicfigur mit Sonnenbrille und einem Stein äh aus einer Hand,
natürlich mit fünf Fingern geformt und ja immer da, wenn's darum ging, klare Aussagen zu machen.
Fünf ist Trümpf zum Beispiel.
Das hat sich echt gehalten, das.
Und und und wenn man das vor vor den sich das vor Augen führt, ne, dass neunzehnhundertneunzig fünf Trümpf war, dann macht auch vieles Sinn,
was einunddreißig Jahre später mit einem Impfpass gemacht wird.
So, wir haben ja in der letzten Sendung schon über Impfpässe gesprochen und wir haben ja auch äh gerade nochmal mit den Kommentaren von User Andron und Sandra Admin grobe Perspektiven darauf ähm.
Vermittelt, sodass wir jetzt die allgemeine Frage, will man das haben oder nicht, jetzt mal im Folgenden ausklammern. Unsere Positionen sind aus der letzten Sendung bekannt. So, jetzt äh hat sich,
DE
das Problem, Impfpass ist eigentlich erschöpfend gelöst mit dem gelben WHO-Impfpass und der ist aber natürlich, würde man ihn jetzt andauernd kontrollieren wollen.
Relativ ungeeignet, der würde schnell an seine Grenzen stoßen, ne.
Man könnte ein digitales Produkt sehr viel schneller checken und das ist der, das Kernargument, überhaupt einen digitalen Impfpass zu machen. Ähm das ist auch der Punkt, warum ich nach wie vor sage,
solange nicht schnell genug geimpft wird und Impfungen nicht allen zur Verfügung stehen, bin ich auch dagegen so etwas einzuführen, weil es eben dann ein Diskriminierung diskriminierungsmerkmal wird,
und genau da arbeiten die aber jetzt dran. Ja, sie möchten, dass die schnell, einfach und überall prüfbar sind. Und zwar ähm nicht nur für
sondern auch für Testergebnisse. Kommen wir auch nochmal zu. So ähm,
und jetzt müssen wir nochmal gucken, wie man überhaupt etwas Digitales fälschungssicher macht.
Grundsätzlich eine digitale Datei oder ein digitaler Wert,
ist ja kopierbar. Ne, also ein ähm QR-Code kannst du auf einen Fotokopierer legen und wenn ich dir jetzt eine Datei gebe, wo drin steht, äh Tim wurde geimpft, dann ist die erstens veränderbar,
und zweitens kopierbar. Ne, das heißt, irgendwas, was digital jetzt in einer Textdatei stünde ist nicht als ähm Impfnachweis tauglich.
Und da gibt es eben diese wunderbare, zauberhafte Funktion der asymmetrischen Kryptographie, dass man Dinge signieren kann. Und das signieren macht man mit Hilfe,
eines Schlüsselpaares. Ja, man hat ein Publicy, also einen öffentlichen Schlüssel, den alle kennen,
können und einen geheimen Schlüssel und dieser geheime Schlüssel, den behält man selber. Und.
Der ist so, wenn ich jetzt ein Inhalt nehme und verschlüssele ihn an,
den Publicy. Dann ist die Entschlüsselung nur noch mit dem Secret Key möglich, ne? So funktioniert's zum Beispiel PGP. Also ne, ich kann an diesem Publicy etwas verschlüsseln und nur die Eignerin des Secret Kies kann das entschlüsseln,
Die gleiche Ope oder eine sehr ähnliche Operation umgekehrt, ermöglicht es der Eignerin des secret Keys, eine Prüfsumme quasi anzubringen über einen digitalen Inhalt,
und ich kann nachher, wenn ich den Inhalt habe und diese Prüfsumme,
verifizieren, dass exakt dieser Inhalt von der Eignerin des Secret Keys signiert wurde. Ändert sich der der Inhalt um nur einen Bit.
Schlägt die Signaturprüfung fehl.
Und genauso würde der Sting mit einem anderen Schlüssel signiert werden, schlägt eben auch die Signaturprüfung fehl. Das sind,
tatsächlich dieses ganze Signaturthema würde ich sagen, ist die die wichtigste fast noch wichtiger als Verschlüsselung, die wichtigste digitale äh,
Erfindung, ja, weil man eben dadurch die Integrität von Inhalten und auch die,
ja Urheberschaft Willensbekundung und sonstiges ähm machen kann.
Und das Entscheidende ist, dass man jetzt quasi daraus Ketten bauen kann und zwar kann ich ja zum Beispiel sagen.
Ich vertraue am Ende nur einem Schlüssel, aber wenn dieser Schlüssel quasi etwas sagt, dann traue ich dem auch. Ja, so könntest du jetzt beispielsweise mit einer einzelnen CA sagen, die signiert dir jetzt Bürgerämter,
Und die Bürgerämter wiederum signieren Ausweise, ja? Oder Impfausweise.
Und wenn du dann in diesem Impfausweis drin hättest, eine Signaturkette, die sich am Ende auf das,
Wurzel des des eine, den einen Key zurückverfolgen lässt, dem du vertraust, dann könntest du quasi sagen, okay, ich traue diesem Impfausweis, weil er signiert wurde vom Bürgeramt, Berlin,
Mitte und das Bürgeramt Berlin Mitte dem das wurde mit dem Wurzelzertifikat dem ich vertraue,
signiert als Städte, die Impfausweise aufstellen darf, ausstellen darf. Ne? Und dann hast du quasi eine Zaktnaturkette.
Die du prüfen kannst. Das ist genau das, was im Übrigen passiert, wenn ihr mit dem Browser eine Webseite besucht, die über HTTPS verschlüsselt ist und dort oben das grüne,
ähm das Grüne äh was ist das? Vorhängeschloss ähm zu sehen ist, dann hat die,
irgendjemand einmal,
nachgewiesen, dass dieses dass diese Webseite unter der Domain oder der Server unter der Domain tatsächlich derjenige ist, mit dem ihr gerade sprecht. Und da birgt also eine Instanz,
der ihr vertraut, beziehungsweise eine Instanz, der jemand vertraut, dem ihr vertraut, dafür, dass diese Webseite echt ist. Das ist deshalb wichtig, weil ihr beim Verschlüssel nicht nur verschlüsseln wollt, sondern auch sicher gehen wollt, dass ihr mit der richtigen Stelle verschlüsselt.
Habe ich das richtig erklärt.
Soweit äh kann ich dem Folgen des Schlosses heutzutage nicht mehr grün, weil diese ganze Unterscheidung mit irgendwie richtig und richtiger äh auch ein bisschen weggelassen wurde. Das.
Stimmt, es wird jetzt einfach knallrot, wenn es nicht verschlüsselt ist, ne.
Genau, also man sieht schon, wenn's nicht passt, aber normalerweise ist es halt so, ja, passt schon und das Schloss sagt, ist überhaupt verschlüsselt. Und man kann dann je nach Browser auch mehr oder weniger einfach, wenn man da mal so draufklickt, auch diese ganze Kette sehen. Also, man kann,
äh schnell sehen, so aha okay. Also ich
probiere das hier grad mal mit allen Browsern, wie das heutzutage so aussieht, also in meinem Lieblingsbrowser. Safari klicke ich da einmal drauf und dann sehe ich genauso diese Kette so, ja, hier Webseite ist validiert worden von dem und dem. Äh
Validator, der wiederum selber von so einer Ruth Zertifizierungsinstanz, ne, so ein die Wurzel quasi so und,
das ist halt eine von denen, denen mein Browser generell vertraut und diese Information kommt quasi mit dem Betriebssystem Update. Und genauso kann man sich das dann halt auch in,
Gesundheitsämtern vorstellen, ne? Regional, Land, Bund et cetera, Europa, was auch immer.
Was an diesem System so genial ist, dass das so also,
von der Struktur der Signaturen her hierarchisch, ja? Ähm kannst du aber beliebig tiefe also beliebig häufig machen, ne? Und das,
die Prüfung selber kannst du offline machen. Also würde ich jetzt, ne, ein,
Texts signieren, wo ich sage, so, Tim ist geimpft und ich wäre, würde hätte außerdem noch das die Befähigung dazugelegt, dass ich befähigt bin, laut,
Hauptzertifikat offerity ähm,
anderen Leuten ebenfalls Ausweise auszustellen, dann könnte diese komplette Prüfung stattfinden, ohne irgendwo nochmal nachzufragen.
Ja? Das ist äh eine eine ziemlich feine Angelegenheit und das ist quasi, ne, auch wenn es von den Signaturketten her ein hierarchisches System ist.
Mit beliebig vielen Parallelen oder äh äh gleichen Hierarchie-Ebenen, völlig in Ordnung,
ist es, in der Prüfung ein äh radikal dezentrales System,
Du bräuchtest nur Updates, wenn du beispielsweise, ne, wenn jetzt aus irgendwelchen Gründen sich herausstellt, okay, hier
dieses äh Gesundheitsamt oder diese Hausärztin hat, äh bösartig äh mehr Impfausweise ausgestellt, als sie durfte, ne? Dann würde es im Prinzip so ein Update geben und dann revox du.
Dann sagst du zum Beispiel, okay, wir revoken den spezifischen Impfausweis von Tim, weil der hat sich das gar nicht spritzen lassen oder wir vertrauen der Ärztin nicht und revoken.
Alle von ihr signierten Impfausweise. Also auf jeder Ebene kannst du auch wieder widerrufen. Dafür brauchst du allerdings dann mal eine Onlineverbindung, aber nur,
für das Update, welchen Zertifikaten oder Intermediaries nicht mehr zu vertrauen ist. Ähm klingt,
Das ist, dass jeder einzelne Prüfvorgang nicht dokumentiert wird und auch nirgendwo zentral getrackt wird oder so, äh ist erstmal für Privatsphäre eine ganz positive Sache. Zweitens, auch für die skalierbarkeit des Systems.
Denn ähm wenn du jetzt irgendwie schnell so Sachen durch,
scannen wollen würdest, ne, wenn das dein Ziel ist, dann äh hilft das natürlich, wenn du zum Beispiel nicht online sein musst, um verifizieren zu können, dass dieser Impfausweis, den du davor vor dir hast,
gültig ist. So, jetzt haben wir den anderen Teil in der letzten Sendung schon besprochen.
Was ist mit den personenbezogenen Daten in dem Impfausweis oder nicht?
Wir haben beim letzten Mal auch kurz darüber gesprochen, dass man mit mehreren so was zum Beispiel auch in einem Personalausweis abbilden könnte und die eigentliche Prüfung stattfinden könnte, ohne dass du deine Identität preisgibst
ja, dass du trotzdem einfach nur sagst, okay, ich bin legitime Eignerin dieses Personalausweises, deswegen habe ich den vor mir, habe ich den in der Hand, ne? Du kannst mich auch auf dem Bild erkennen,
und dieser Ausweis hat,
das Merkmal und kann beweisen, dass er äh geimpft ist, weil er eben eine Signaturkette entsprechend vorweisen kann. Wenn man das jetzt aber mit einem QR-Code machen würde, ne, dann könnte man zum Beispiel so etwas machen, wie ich mache jetzt einen,
will nur sagen, was das simpelste System wäre. In dem QR-Code stehen, was weiß ich, die letzten sieben Ziffern der Personalausweisnummer oder was auch immer, ja? Der Impfstoff und das Datum,
Die Signatur der Intermediate CA und du bist fertig. Ne? Und dann könntest du diesen QR-Code scannen. Das Ding könnte dir sofort.
Offline sagen, alles klar, der ist gültig oder nicht und würde dir zum Beispiel die letzten Zeichen der Personalausweisnummer anzeigen, zu der
Ausweis gehört. Ja und vielleicht noch dazu sagen, männlich, weiblich oder Geburtsdatum, um wenn du ganz genau prüfen möchtest, ne? Fertig, mehr brauchst du nicht.
Oder oder die komplette Personalausweisnummer ist ja auch kein Problem. Dann zeigst du halt deinen Personalausweis dazu und damit ist auch der Bezug zu dir klar und das war's.
Ich werbe jetzt mal extra nicht die komplette Personalausweisnummer genommen, weil du musst ja auch immer davon ausgehen, dass vielleicht die scande Personen bösartig ist
ja? Und dann würdest du vielleicht nicht die ganze äh Preis geben, ja? Zum Beispiel würdest du du musstest deinen Namen nicht preisgeben, warum sollst du den da reinschreiben, ne?
Ja. Oder? Okay, also so eine Kombination von Teilinformationen, die zumindestens sehr unwahrscheinlich machen, dass irgendjemand mit einem anderen Ausweis diese Kriterien erfüllt in dem Moment.
Ja. Ähm entscheidend ist, du bräuchtest.
Immer nochmal eine Bindung an irgendein zweites Authentifizierungsmerkmal. Oder du hostest halt wirklich auf die Personalausweise drauf und bist auch dann daran gebunden. Am Ende geht's ja darum, du musst irgendwie verhindern,
dass in der WG ein so ein Ding liegt, ne? Und äh jede damit einfach äh rausmarschiert. Aber so könntest du das machen. Und dafür bräuchtest du,
Noppes,
Nichts. Alles, was du machen musst, ist die jeweiligen, die Impfzertifizierenden stellen mit etwas ausstatten, dass sie solche Zertifikate anbringen können, ne? Das ist ein ist eine Herausforderung. Könnte man bei helfen
Aber du hast keine Abhängigkeit und es wäre vor allem der Ausstellungsvorgang würde dich nichts mehr kosten und der Prüfungsvorgang würde dich nichts mehr kosten.
Es ginge offline und du hast es ähm nicht äh,
äh äh es ging offline und du du könntest es also machen, dass beim Datensammeln bei der Prüfung selber du digital nichts ausliest, was die Anonymität der Person gefährdet,
So. Wie gesagt, geht noch besser. Das war das, was ich in der letzten Sendung angesprochen habe, aber sagen wir mal so, das wäre die einfachste Lösung, das mit einem QR-Code zu machen.
Aber das hat natürlich äh totale Nachteile, ne, ist ja klar. Also erstmal ist das ja viel zu einfach und es würde ja auch gar nichts kosten.
Stimmt. Kann also ja. Genau. Und und hat keinen Blockchain.
Auch das noch, dann kann es für die Zukunft nicht gemacht sein, denn nur mit Blockchain geht es in die Zukunft.
Jetzt müssen wir Blockchain erklären.
Haben wir mehrere Bitcoin Profiteure auf dem Internet nachdrücklich bestätigt.
Dass ich dir Blockchain nochmal erklären soll, ne.
Nein, das das ich keine Ahnung davon habe. Auf jeden Fall.
Muss ich mal ganz kurz sagen, also Kai auch glaube ich ganz klar sagen, ich, was eine Blockchain ist, habe ich gelernt von Andreas Book und zwar in CRE. Ich weiß nicht, welche Nummer. Ja?
Schon eine Weile her.
Ja natürlich, muss jetzt zehn, elf Jahre her sein.
Ja, ich gucke gerade mal.
CCC Urgestein will ich mal sagen ähm.
CRE einhundertzweiundachtzig elektronisches Geld vom zwölften Sechsten zwanzig elf. Ist also wirklich fast zehn Jahre her.
Ja. Ja. Also da habe ich das äh da meine ich oder ich glaube das ich hab's vorher versucht zu verstehen, aber in weiß, dass das die beste Erklärung ist, die ich so ähm die die mir so damals zugänglich war.
Ähm Grüße an Andreas an der Stelle. So, jetzt ähm ist das so.
Ähm also ich erkläre erstmal nur, was ja also eine Blockchain ist.
Erklär doch erstmal, warum wir jetzt überhaupt Blockchain erklären müssen.
Fünf hat.
Genau, also die deutsche Bundesregierung hat äh gesagt
wir machen jetzt mal einen Impfpass und die einfache und naheliegende Lösung, die auf Technik aufbaut, für die wir jetzt jahrzehntlang gekämpft haben, dass sie überhaupt mal da ist
die wird dann einfach ignoriert, weil wäre noch schöner, wenn man das jetzt irgendwie auch noch so benutzt, wie man's ja früher immer gesagt hat. Es war ja immer so dieses Versprechen. Ja, der der elektronische Personalausweis, der muss jetzt kommen, weil
sind ja ganz viele Anwendungen dann auch mit möglich. Nur diese Anwendung hat noch keiner gesehen, ja?
Hauptsache, die Polizei kann halt mit einmal zip irgendwie die Daten darunter lesen und dann war eigentlich schon alle zufrieden, aber jetzt mal wirklich was damit zu bauen
für Bürger auch irgendwie
Sinnvoll ist, wie ich melde mein Auto im Internet an oder sonst irgendwas, wo man hier in Berlin drei Monate braucht, bis man einen Termin kriegt, um dann irgendwie nochmal drei Monate auf diesen Termin zu warten,
äh
Es ist.
Ja, es ist es ist ganz schlimm. Also man hat jetzt beschlossen,
macht das alles ganz anders, weil Zukunft und überhaupt. Und jetzt haben wir auch jahrelang Blockchain gefördert und wussten überhaupt nicht warum. Also müssen wir jetzt auch zeigen, dass es irgendwas gebracht hat.
Also, zur Blockchain kurz vorab.
Was ist das?
Die Blockchain selber ist eine sehr viel ältere Empfindung, die hieß früher einfach noch Merkelbaum, aber äh oder Hashke Kette. Aber seitdem sie Blockchain heißt,
wurde damit einspezifisches Problem gelöst. Ein spezifisches, sehr kleines Problem wurde damit besonders elegant gelöst. Und seitdem,
wollen alle dieses Problem haben. Auch wenn sie es nicht haben. Und ein elektronischer Impfpass hat das Problem nicht. Gut, ich habe gerade bei den bei den
Signaturen und bei den CAs erklärt, dass du am Ende ein Vertrauensanker hast. Und dieser Vertrauensanker, wenn der sich, wenn der nicht mehr in deinem Interesse agiert
ja? Oder du dem nicht so hundertprozentig vertraust? Dann ist das CA Modell ungeeignet für dich.
Also sagen wir mal so, du guckst da so drauf und denkst dir so, Bundesrepublik Deutschland, was ist das denn jetzt? Ich kann mir ja viel erzählen.
Zum Beispiel eine GmbH ist Tattoo nicht vertraust.
Kann zum Beispiel sein.
Oder wenn du zum
wenn du zum Beispiel feststellst, dass in deinem Browser irgendwie so und so viel amerikanische und so und so viel Chinesische vorinstalliert sind, denen du bedingungslos vertraust, aber ne, also es hat, es gibt eine zentrale Autorität.
Ne? Und mit der Blockchain löst du, also wenn wir jetzt mal den ganzen Bitcoin ClimbIM obendrum,
nochmal wegschneiden. Eine Blockchain grundsätzlich funktioniert so
Du hast eine Kette von Prüfsummen. Und wenn du jetzt etwas in dieser Blockchain ablegst, ne, du hast einen neuen Inhalt von der Blockchain, äh den du der Blockchain hinzufügst
dann errechnest du die Prüfsumme dieses Inhalts. Also zum Beispiel, da steht jetzt,
naives Beispiel. Tim wurde geimpft, so. Dann machst du davon eine Prüfsumme und jetzt nimmst du,
Die Prüfsumme von dem letzten Inhalt der Blockchain, die nimmst du dann noch dazu. Also du nimmst Tim, wurde geimpft und der letzte Eintrag der Kette hat die Prüfsumme so und so,
Diese beiden Werte nimmst du und machst daraus wieder eine Prüfsumme. Jetzt steht da also, was weiß ich. Tim wurde geimpft und der letzte Inhalt der Kette hat die Prüfsumme eins.
Wird die Prüfung errechnet? Drei. Jetzt fügst das der Blockchain hinzu. Und jetzt kommt als nächstes, Linus wurde geimpft. Nee, nicht als nächstes. Ich bin ja viel jünger. Aber okay, also ähm äh irgendjemand anders wurde geimpft.
Ähm.
Und der letzte Inhalt der Blockchain war drei, weil das ja die Prüfsumme war, die bei Tim rausgekommen ist. Jetzt kommt die Prüfsumme acht raus. Und das Nächste muss jetzt quasi wieder sagen, ah, alles klar. Michael wurde geimpft und die letzte Prüfsumme war acht und
jetzt kannst du quasi diese Kette durchgehen und sie ist jetzt geschützt.
Gegen retrograde Veränderung. Es kann jetzt niemand auf äh später behaupten, ich wurde aber vor Tim geimpft.
Weil damit die Kette kaputt gemacht würde mit dieser Behauptung, ne? Die Verifizierung würde bis da und ab da nicht mehr weitergehen. Und ähm diese Eigenschaft, dass du nachträglich nichts mehr in der Kette verändern kannst,
macht die Blockchain geeignet für Transaktionsbücher,
Das ist eigentlich das, was Bitcoin dann ist. Bitcoin ist eine Liste von Transaktionen,
im Prinzip immer drin steht, ne, was weiß ich, Konto X, Y, hat so und so viel Bitcoin an äh Konto abwiesen und dann wird das dahin geschrieben. Und,
um den Kontostand aller Konten herauszufinden, musst du dich einmal vollständig dadurch lesen. Dann merkst du dir natürlich, was da steht, aber du kannst am Ende alle alle Transaktionen in dieser,
Kette verifizieren und vor allem kann niemand nachträglich behaupten, mehr Geld oder weniger Geld gehabt zu haben.
Ähm der Begriff, der da sehr häufig verwendet wird, ist Ledger, also es heißt so etwas wie Kontobuchbestandsbuch, Wirtschaftsbuch oder sowas, ne?
Tassenbuch und ähm da ist eben entscheidend, dass äh dass du nicht nachträglich Dinge ändern kannst. Das ist eine sehr elegante Lösung. Die Blockchain, wenn,
dass da ein Bedrohungsszenario ist. Bei Bitcoin wurde das Konzept,
dahingehend erweitert. Da gehen wir jetzt aber nicht mehr drauf ein, dass diese Blockchain verteilt wird und das Recht, dort was reinzuschreiben.
Durch die Lösung eines schweren mathematischen Problemes erlangt wird,
Und das ist das, was beim Bitcoin Mining passiert. Da wird ein vorgegebenes Problem gelöst und diejenige, die es als erstes gelöst hat, darf den nächsten Eintrag in die Blockchain machen,
Und bei diesem neuen Eintrag machen darf sie sich ein selbst einen bestimmten Betrag gutschreiben. Das ist die Belohnung dafür, dass sie gewonnen hat. Das heißt, was diese meiner machen, ist, am laufenden Band um die Wette rechnen.
Um dieses das Recht zu bekommen, den nächsten Blog zu schreiben. So,
ganz vereinfacht Bitcoin. So und wenn du das so machst, dann hast du.
Hier mit diesem um die Wette rechnen, hast du ein Konsensusnetz, ja und jetzt hast du äh quasi einen öffentlichen Konsensus darüber, welche Transaktionen stattgefunden haben.
Wer wie viel auf seinem Konto hat und du hast keine Abhängigkeit mehr von einer CA. Dafür rechnen alle sich wie die Irren um die Wette, ja? Aber in dem Fall, in diesem einen spezifischen Fall nachträgliche Veränderung ist dein Bedrohungsmodell.
Und du willst kein, du traust keiner, zentralen Instanz. Dann willst du eine Blockchain haben.
Wenn das nicht der Fall ist, da willst du keinen Workshop haben. Du brauchst keinen Workshop.
Weil es sinnlos ist. Das macht da auch keiner mit irgendwie am Ende sind auch die Blockchains, die jetzt hier zur Diskussion stehen.
Sind ja gar keine.
Das sind gar keine richtigen Blockchains, sondern das sind halt einfach im Wesentlichen einfach nur aufgeblasene Datenbanken, in denen halt die Informationen reingeschrieben werden.
Aber irgendwie davon träumen so eine große verteilte Datenbank zu sein, in der man alles nachschlagen kann. Aber man muss hier nicht alles nachschlagen. Wir wollen halt nur eine einzige Information irgendwo speichern
und sagen, die stimmt und dann reicht's das halt einfach,
zu unterschreiben mit einer Autorität, wie man das auf allen anderen öffentlichen Dokumenten ja auch macht. Das ist ein Stempel von der Behörde oder ein Siegel oder was auch immer, je nach Sicherheitsanforderung
mehr oder weniger Aufwand getrieben und das ist dann sozusagen dein öffentliches Dokument, was du vorzeigen kannst.
Was der wichtige Punkt ist, den du gerade nicht so betont hast, wie ich den wichtig zu betonen finde, ist,
Wenn du etwas mit einer Blockchain prüfen möchtest, musst du den aktuellen Stand der Blockchain prüfen. Könnte sich ja was geändert haben.
Das heißt, du musst online sein und der zweite Punkt, wo du sagst, eigentlich müssen alle die prüfen können, die Blockchain vorhalten.
Ja, dann macht es Sinn, eine Blockchain zu nutzen. Aber weil das eine völlig bekloppte Anforderung ist, haben sie genau das wieder rausgenommen aus dem Deutschen Impfpass und du vertraust jetzt einer zentralen Instanz, die dir sagt, jo, steht in der Blockchain drin, mach dir mal keine Sorgen. Was, was
so so bescheuert. Mir ist völlig unklar, wie man auf die Idee kommen kann,
Also, was haben die getan? Es gibt einen QR-Code. In dem QR-Code steht eine URL drin,
die ist irgendwie W wie HTTPS UB Ulbricht DE Ulbricht DE und dann paar Werte, ja? Du gehst jetzt auf eine Webseite,
Und dein Prüfer, also eine, die prüfende Person scannt jetzt den QR-Code, geht äh entnimmt dem,
QR-Code, die Klartextinformation, dass er jetzt zum Beispiel steht Tim Pritlaff, ja? Und Geburtsdatum und was da sonst noch alles drin steht,
ähm rechnet daraus einen Hash und fragt dann eine boah, der krieg nicht mehr hin. Eine.
Ulbrich, ulbich, Urbirch.
Ist glaube ich so schwer ist es auch nicht.
Eine und sagt, sag mir doch mal bitte, ob der Hash in dem in deiner Blockchain drinsteht,
Jetzt kommt aber noch dazu, damit denen die Blockchain nicht zu groß wird, wird nicht für jede einzelne Person ähm
ein Eintrag in diese Blockchain gemacht, sondern immer im Paket
Also du nimmst, ne, da steht jetzt nicht als ein Block in der Blockchain steht nicht. Tim wurde geimpft, sondern Tim wurde geimpft, Max wurde geimpft, Thomas wurde geimpft, Dinos wurde geimpft, Michael wurde geimpft, ja? Und dieser ganze Block steht jetzt in der Blockchain,
Was natürlich auch den Look ab für diese Filternot noch mal viel teurer macht.
Ähm um dir dann am Ende zu sagen, jo, der steht in der Blockchain drin. In der Blockchain selber steht aber nur der Hashtag über die ganzen Informationen,
sodass in der Blockchain selbst nicht die Privatsphäre relevanten Daten gespeichert sind, was schon mal ganz gut ist. Ja, du hast wenigstens keine zentrales Impfregister, was du nämlich sonst mit so einem Onlinesystem bräuchtest. Aber,
derjenige oder diejenige, die deinen QR-Codes kennen, die kriegen ja die Informationen, die stehen ja in dem in dem QR-Code drin.
Und.
Die kann also, die können also trotzdem, die können, die verifizieren und können sich merken, wer alles wann da war und ob die Person geimpft ist und seit wann. Ne?
Nummer, mit einer Test Identification Nummer.
Mit eindeutig und allem. Ja.
Datum des Tests, Methode des Tests.
Was alles komplett überflüssig ist, zumindest ist es überflüssig, das in digital zu liefern.
Er gerade meinte, du könntest alternativ einfach die letzten paar Ziffern vom Personalausweis ausgeben und dann diese Identitätsprüfung, die muss ja auch bei diesem System machen.
Die könnte es dir einfach analog lassen, aber hier liefern die halt Name, Geburtsdatum und so weiter mit,
in dem in dem QR-Code, damit's auch schön brav digital äh als Check-In gespeichert werden kann, wer wann da war. Der Abgleich äh findet äh ähm.
Eben hier digitalisiert statt und damit kannst du eben die Daten alle korrigieren. So, jetzt kommt das nächste Problem, wie registrierst du eine Ärztin? Wir wollen ja,
hat man uns versprochen, hat hat Jens Spahn uns versprochen, irgendwann in grauer Zukunft werden wir uns einfach bei einer Hausärztin äh impfen lassen können.
Jetzt hätte ich ja gerade auch gesagt, die muss natürlich äh jetzt irgendwie sich die Autoisierung bekommen, ja. In diesem Fall muss sie sich dann eben bei dem UB U Bier IBM System anmelden,
Das ist dann wohl wahrscheinlich auch der Grund, warum IBM da noch mit drinsteckt, ja? Und äh die Arztpraxen müssen sich dann eben bei denen einmal authentifizieren ähm
da sei dann übrigens an äh hier diese ganzen Heilberufeausweise erinnert und die äh Sachen, die da
Martin Schiersig und Kollegen regelmäßig auf den Kongressen verifizieren, wo eben diese Heilberufe ausweise ähm irgendwo an die Käsetheke bestellt wurden, ne?
Das heißt, das bringt auch nochmal durchaus Probleme. Da würde ich aber sagen, das hätte ein CA-Modell äh im weitesten Sinne ebenfalls.
Dann kann's natürlich, also Schlüssel und so weiter, das hast du alles das Problem, ne? So, aber das heißt, mit dem mit dem,
System, was worauf Deutschland sich jetzt geeinigt hat. Wer äh aus irgendwelchen Gründen werden diese Daten dann aus Gründen, die keine Sau versteht, werden diese Daten dann in fünf Blockchains abgelegt,
Also eine hätte gereicht und selbst die würdest du nicht brauchen.
Erst recht nicht, wenn du trotzdem einen zentralen oder auf mehrere Server verteilte Filternots fragst, steht das in der Blockchain drin? Tim, wie kommt man da drauf?
Ich ich habe nur äh Vermutungen und es könnte damit
tun haben, dass die Bundesregierung jetzt jahrelang Blockchain gefordert hat und äh Geld rausgeschmissen hat zum Fenster. Und jetzt irgendwie auch mal zeigen muss, dass es ja was gebracht hat, dass man das dafür braucht. Ein Aspekt, wenn ich das jetzt nicht falsch verstanden habe,
hast du auch noch gar nicht erwähnt. Also wir reden ja davon, man man bringt sozusagen sein, in Anführungsstrichen Beweis, seinen Impfbeweis,
mit in Form eines QR-Codes. Wir alle wissen, Menschen können QR-Codes nicht lesen.
Ja? Man tut das dann mit so einem Handy. So, was ist jetzt der normale Use Case? Der normale Use Case ist, du scanntst dieses Ding. Dann kommt da so eine Webseite hoch,
und sagt, hallo, hier Corona-Testüberprüfung, äh hier die Daten, die da äh stehen, alles super. Klick mal auf, dann blinkt die kurz grün,
und fertig. So,
Bin ich jetzt aber nicht UB DE da rein schreibe, sondern Ubrich D oder Bricho DE oder keine Ahnung irgendeinen Scheißdreck, ja, und ich baue mir einfach auf meinem eigenen scheiß kleinen Webserver,
exakt genau dieselbe Webseite nach, die wenn du aufklickst, einen grünen Button macht, das merkt kein Schwein.
Also es ist einfach so was von lächerlich wie kann man auf so einen Kack kommen?
Fünf Blockchains.
Wieso überhaupt fünf? Eine ist schon zu viel. Das schmerzt einfach.
Das ist auch äh das das genau das, was du gerade geschildert hast, hat ähm Hanno Böck an dieser Stelle natürlich auch herzlich gegrüßt schon im äh Februar äh demonstriert,
als ist ja ich würde sagen IT-Security-Experte und Journalist.
Und der hat dann auch äh äh Impfausweis Punkt NET eine Webseite gebaut, wo sich äh jede eine schön äh Impfausweis stellen kann, so fit für.
Stimmt, das sieht doch genauso aus, alles klar. Aber richtig mit Cookie-Meldung und alles. Kannst du einfach eintragen, Name? Warte mal, das ist.
Genau das. Test Identifikation.
Was haben wir heute? Zwanzig einundzwanzig null drei zehn Stunde, was haben wir hier? Frühstück, zehn Uhr dreißig.
Testmethode, PCR, klar, immer nur vom Besten und natürlich negativ. So, verify, läuft. Da ist mein QR-Code.
Oben gleich auch mit der URL und so, sieht genauso aus. Ja, geil.
Alles easy. Impfen impfen hat noch nie.
Bin geimpft. Yes, yes. Ich klicke mir gleich mal ein Kinoticket.
Äh
Klar, jetzt wissen diese Leute natürlich auch von diesem Problem mit anderen Worten, die werden dir natürlich dann irgendwann so eine Check-App äh an anschwatzen, die hm,
dann sicher stellt sich nur vom UBI-Server sagen zu lassen, was ein gültiger ähm äh Impfausweis ist und was nett Impfausweis dot net.
Checkt ja auch jeder.
Alle Sorgen zu machen, vor allem weil, hör mir auf. Und.
Du brauchst keine Blockchain. Du brauchst keine. Also für das, was was dann am Ende passiert bei der Verifikation, ne? Würde es genauso reichen.
Wenn die einfach irgendein fucking Server hätten, wo sie draufschreiben, ja wurde geimpft oder nein, ne? Äh da brauchen sie nicht noch hinten fünf Blockchains dran, das ist völlig völlig irrelevant, es ist völlig irrelevant,
Es ist du kannst nicht so.
Problem nicht verstanden. Problem Impfausweis nicht verstanden, Problem nicht verstanden und das gleich fünfmal hintereinander. Und aber weißt du, was tatsächlich der Grund ist, dass die fünf Blockchains haben?
Nee, ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht meinen Schimmer.
Ist das nicht dein Ernst?
Ich glaube schon, was anderes kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Falls sie sich verrechnet oder so oder Mathe irgendwie auf einmal.
Weißt du, wer wer weiß, ob einer abgeschaltet.
Oder falls ein recht ein Fehler ist. Und die CPO sich irgendwie beiseite legen und sagen so, ja nee, kann ich irgendwie heute nicht ausrechnen. Probier mal. Probier mal mit der anderen Blockchain.
So peinlich.
Es gibt einen äh sehr schönen äh Medien-Blogpost, der das äh nochmal ein bisschen ähm auf höherer Flugebene.
Ähm,
analysiert, den wir auch in den Shownotes haben, der den fortgeschrittenen Leserinnen empfohlen wird, wenn sie sich da nochmal genauer mit auseinandersetzen möchten, auch mit ja, komplizierteren ähm und sinnvolleren Systemen. Der ist von,
Stefan Adolf. Ähm Auslöser dafür war äh zumindest steht das so im Text ein Tweet von mir.
Ja, mein Tweet war ja, ähm.
So so der Dinge, die der digitale Impf was wird kryptographisch signiert und in insgesamt fünf Blockchains hinterlegt. Kann mir bitte jemand erklären, warum man dafür überhaupt eine Blockchain braucht?
Und wofür? Vier weitere. So, das äh genau, da da um darauf zu antworten, mit nein, gibt's eben diesen schönen Blogpost und der kommt zu einem Fazit.
Wie gesagt, der Blogpost ist noch mal sehr viel tiefer gehend und ist einen, die sich da weiter einarbeiten wollen, sehr ans Herz gelegt. Fazit,
vor dem Hintergrund der mit Hochdruck vorangetriebenen, selbst souveränen Identitäten ist es unlogisch, für Impfzertifikate auf eine Lösung zu setzen. Die erstens, sich an keinen semantischen Standard hält. Zweitens,
jedem, also der Prüferin,
unnötige Menge an privaten Informationen offenlegt. Drittens, Daten unnötigerweise auf obskuren Blockchains verankert. Viertens,
preetäre Lösungen zur Arzt Identifikation angewiesen ist.
Fünftens, sich an keine Regeln internationaler Interopeabilität hält und sechstens zur Überprüfung der Identität des nachweisenden Weitere,
analoge Merkmale zwingend voraussetzt. Diesen letzten Punkt, das wäre das gewesen, das System, was ich in der letzten,
Sendung schon angesprochen habe, was man jetzt beispielsweise auf Basis einer Smartcard Video äh Personalausweis hätte bauen können. Das ist in dem Blogpost auch nochmal,
besser beschrieben. Ähm spezifisch Frage ist ja auch vor allem hier die internationale Zusammenarbeit. Wir wollen einander ja nicht nur am Eingang zum Kino diskriminieren, sondern auch an internationalen Grenzen, ne? Und da wäre jetzt,
naheliegend wäre halt ein CA Modell gewesen mit einem einheitlichen Standard, was du da reinschreibst und dann gibt die ähm.
Ist beispielsweise die WHO
die Haupt CA, die stellt jedem Land eine Intermediary aus und dann können die Länder äh äh oder die Staaten äh unter sich selber nochmal so viele Intermediorys ausstellen, wie sie äh zu einer sinnvollen,
Umsetzung des Verfahrens brauchen und schon hättest du ein weltweit prüfbaren Impfpass in Form eines,
äh QR-Codes, wärst du fertig gewesen, ne? Wie gesagt, noch schöner wär's, mit mit Smartcards, äh mit einem Challenge Response Verfahren und sauberer, kryptografischer Prüfung, aber,
Lassen wir das. Ich weiß nicht, was ich dazu sagen sollte.
Es ist auch wirklich ja, es reiht sich wunderbar ein in in die in meine neuen, meine neue Hoffnungslosigkeit.
Twitter ist Twitter zu diesen fünf Blockchains ist äh wirklich ein Traum, ne, also kann ich kann ich nicht anders sagen. Ich fand auch deinen Tweetstorm, also Tim hatte heute auch so einen Maddown. War heute, oder?
Ja
Tim hat den Twitter Maddown.
Das braucht man manchmal einfach.
Möchtest du das vorlesen oder ich?
Ach mit der ja, weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt den ganzen Tritt vorlesen muss, worauf wolltest du jetzt hinaus?
Bin ja eigentlich Berufsoptimist, aber langsam kriege ich das Gefühl, dieses Land kriegt einfach die Kurve nicht mehr. Das führt jetzt vielleicht etwas weit, aber es ist ja nicht so, als ob uns der ganze Scheiß nicht schon seit Jahren von anderen vorgeführt wird, wie es,
Trotzdem scheint,
alles in der, wozu braucht man das alles, Wolke und dem, das ist aber zu teuer, Nebel und den haben wir ja noch nie so gemacht, Dunst, eingehüllt zu sein.
Und jetzt kommt mein Lieblings-Tweet, möchtest du dir sagen.
Nee, Sommertour.
Aber jetzt irgendwann kommt dann einer und sagt, jetzt wird alles geil. Jetzt haben wir das verstanden. Und jetzt haben wir fünf Blockchain an den Start gebracht.
Und ich will mich einfach nur noch rissen.
Ich meine, dieses ganze Breitband für alle Thema, das ist jetzt schon so ein Methusalem-Thema, aber es hat
hat immer noch keiner begriffen, dass man hier einfach mal eine nationale Infrastruktur aufbauen muss. Die einzige Kleinteile zugänglich sein muss. Es checkt einfach keiner. Es klicken,
Es passiert nichts. Schicken Sie uns doch ein Fax, dann denken wir vielleicht noch einmal drüber nach, diese Schmerzen. Fünf.
Ist so viel depressiver essen, um mir dieses fortwerdende Ehe zu ertragen. Ein Jahr Pandemie und es gibt noch nicht mal einen Konsens darüber, dass unser Schulsystem im Arsch ist. Also heute, das geht ja immer falsch.
Ein Jahr Pandemie und uns wird immer noch und und uns wird immer noch viel blöde daran gearbeitet,
anzufangen, womit andere Länder seit Jahren fertig sind, aber uns geil finden, das können wir. Das sind rumschlägt permanent zu. Und wenn wir, wenn hier mal was erfunden wird, sagen wir mal Solarzelt oder Willkraft, dann muss das natürlich auch,
gemacht werden. Ja, ich weiß, angefangen mit Rechnung und jetzt schon beim Klimawandel angekommen, habe Verständnis, es macht mich einfach wahnsinnig, okay, du hast gar nicht mehr aufgehört, Tim,
Da kam nachher nochmal.
Es ist einfach es reicht einfach langsam. Es reicht. Womit wollt ihr uns noch foltern? Gott.
Gestern, gestern hat ähm ah Mann, jetzt fällt mir der, mir fällt mir nicht genau ein, wer das äh wer das gepostet hat, denn eines deiner Lieblingsmemes hier äh mit dem.
Äh
Fünf Blockchains.
Genau.
So peinlich. Es ist so peinlich und ich will ich will nicht wissen,
will nicht wissen, wo wer da noch wahrscheinlich hat da irgend so ein Unterhändler von.
Noch gesagt so, Alter, Leute, der ist wahrscheinlich rausgegangen, hat an Handy genommen, hat gesagt, einer ihr klaut nicht, ich habe den noch, noch zwei Blockchains extra verkauft.
Und,
gefressen
Was ist was? Was ist diesem Land zugestoßen? Was, was ist passiert? Oh Gott.
Linus geht einfach überhaupt nicht mehr. Es ist einfach hier ertrage es nicht mehr. Manno! Oho!
Corona und das ist genau die gleiche Story wieder von vorne. Oh Gott,
Ich will Schmerzensgeld haben.
Sobald ich meinen.
Ach, ich habe ja schon einen. Dank. Oh Mann, ist das.
Schmerzensgeld. Zugstehen von
es uns nicht überweisen, weil sehr viel Tarngenerator verloren haben. Alle dreißig Sekunden neue Tat berechnen müssen überweisen zu können.
Äh ein ein Tweet fand ich auch sehr schön.
Der war von fünf das digitale.
Ging alles abgesichert.
Okay.
Das müssen wir uns wieder fangen.
Das erste Thema.
Das Zweite kommt sie gleich.
So aufm frühen Morgen.
Machen gleich zu. Na ja, dann darf ich heute nur ein Bier trinken, aber ist auch vielleicht auch besser so.
Was dich spätis machen bei dir vormittags zu?
Um elf, ja.
Aber ich habe gehört, die sind ganz seriös. Es ist Informationsmedium. Ein bisschen am Riemen reißen, ja.
Blockchain haben wir gerade richtig erklärt. Entschuldigung, also wir sind das erste Medium.
Überhaupt in dem Kontext mal erklärt hast. Alle anderen nur so.
Nicht zwei, nicht vier, fünf. Geil. Ah.
Okay.
Das ist so ein bisschen so ein bisschen wie dieser Gigahertz-Krieg irgendwie mit den PCs früher äh meiner hat aber irgendwie drei echt drei Komma zwei.
Ein Scheibe. So, kommen wir zum nächsten Thema.
Corona.
Corona-App, ja. Also.
Wir wurden jetzt von von der ganzen Reihe Hörerinnen äh gebeten, wir sollten doch mal äh was zu der Luca App sagen. Und da frage ich mich, ernsthaft, ne,
hört ihr uns eigentlich nicht zu? Darüber haben wir äh im Dezember Lenz gesprochen,
fing nämlich diese dieser Werbekreuzzug an, von äh dem dem coolsten Schwaben, den sie finden konnten. Smudo, das habe ich damals nämlich schon äh,
erwähnt hier in der Sendung, haben auch schon drüber gesprochen, aber machen wir gerne nochmal.
Denn äh das Thema äh hat ja jetzt auch an äh medialem,
Interesse gewonnen. Und zwar ähm beschreiben wir heute im Prinzip äh drei.
Drei Corona App-Konzepte nochmal. Die Corona-Warn-App haben wir hier schon oft genug besprochen, wie die funktioniert. Insofern fassen wir uns da dazu kurz, äh klären sie aber nochmal.
Grundsätzlich. Ähm.
Dann sprechen wir über die äh Luca-App und dann über Crowd-Notify, ein Konzept, was wir ja auch schon besprochen haben, aber auch vor einigen Monaten,
und äh wir werden alle drei ein bisschen erklären,
Wichtig ist, wir beschreiben, was diese Ansätze machen. Wir empfehlen keine Apps und wir raten auch nicht davon ab, in dieser Sendung,
Wir informieren darüber. Äh dieser Hinweis ist sehr nötig und ich bitte den auch ernst zu nehmen, weil ich inzwischen seit Monaten von diesen Lukaleuten belagert werde,
die andauernd in der Inbox die Fragen andauernd Leute, ob sie nicht in Kontakt zu mir herstellen können, die Leute melden sich dann bei mir.
Inzwischen belagern sie die Airfas, also die lokalen Gruppen des CCC und äh wollen immer irgendwie, dass jemand ihre App gut findet und ähm ist wirklich ein bisschen aggressiv.
Und äh ich möchte äh eigentlich glaube ich, dass die mit Smudo,
ausreichend Werbung für ihre App haben. Ist ja jetzt auch von Erfolg gekrönt. Insofern werden wir das jetzt hier mal äh erklären,
was die verschiedenen Ansätze sind, werden die natürlich auch äh,
einen oder anderen Nebensatz bewerten, aber wir werden keine abschließende Bewertung vornehmen, denn es gilt, was wir damals,
in den zehn Steinen des CCC geschrieben haben, kann man auch heute noch nachlesen
ohne Anspruch auf Vollständigkeit benennen wir in diesem Beitrag über die zehn Prüfstände Mindestanforderungen
denen eine Corona-App entsprechen muss, um gesellschaftlich und technisch überhaupt tolerabl zu sein. Der CCC wird aus grundsätzlichen Erwägungen unter keinen Umständen jemals eine konkrete Implementierung mit Zustimmung, Empfehlung
oder gar einem Zertifikat oder Prüfsiegel versehen, es obliegt den Entwicklern von Contact Tracing System die Erfüllung dieser Anforderung zu belegen
oder von unabhängigen Dritten. Belegen zu lassen. Und das gilt für Luca genauso wie für jeder andere App. Ähm.
Kurzzusammenfassung, Corona-Warn-App will messen, Nähe zwischen Personen und wenn hier ein Schwellwert für die Nähe,
und die Zeit überschritten wird, wird eine Warnung ausgelöst und zwar darüber, dass
dass beide Apps oder ich beide Apps, beide Handys jeweils kurz aussenden, die sich regelmäßig wechseln und diese Codes werden veröffentlicht und in dem Moment, wo ein Code, den du empfangen hast, auch veröffentlicht wurde, ähm und du in deiner eigenen Datenbank drinstehen hast
lange genug empfangen hast, löst.
Dein Handy aus, dadurch ist die Datenhaltung vollständig dezentral, es gibt also keine zentrale Datenbank Jena.
Die sich irgendwie getroffen haben oder so. Ähm das ist das Corona-Warn-App-Konzept. So, jetzt stößt dieses Konzept auf eine ähm.
Anforderungen.
Das Konzept nicht gerecht wird. Und das ist die in Deutschland immer noch geltende ähm Verordnung, glaube ich, die die ähm.
Die Corona-Schutzverordnung der Länder sind das, die auf der Infektionsschutzverordnung des Bundes basieren.
Ah super, da kannst du besser erklären als ich. Weißt du da noch mehr drüber?
Na ja gut, ich meine, das sind dann halt immer die jeweils geltenden Verordnungen, was denn so gilt. So, was man darf, was man nicht darf, was
besondere dann eben auch Gastronomie äh tun muss, selbst wenn sie mal geöffnet haben et cetera, gerade was eben in dieser Erfassung der Personen betrifft, die dort zu Gast sind und,
Na ja, das orientiert sich halt äh an dieser Idee eines Zettels, auf die man Dinge draufschreibt und schreibt dann halt entsprechend vor, dass da.
Bestimmte Informationen zu sammeln sind, wenn Leute denn zu Gast sind.
So und die ist, das ist jetzt in der Gastronomie üblicherweise, ne, dass sie Kontaktdaten von dir erfassen müssen.
Und die Lösung dafür waren äh
unterschiedlichster Form äh digitale Lösungen, die wir hier im Lokbuch ja auch besprochen haben. Wir erinnern uns äh so viel war bei uns und hat uns erzählt von äh zwei ein oder zwei Systemen, die das zehrt auseinandergenommen hat, äh weil die natürlich alle mit der heißen Nadel gestrickt waren. Also es gibt diese Anforderung per Verordnung,
Erfasse irgendwie mehr oder weniger vollständige Daten deiner Gäste. Und Luca.
Ist ein System, was diese Anforderungen erfüllen möchte und dann auch noch so gut wie möglich,
Des Weiteren um das Dritte auch noch kurz anzuteasern, bevor ich jetzt dann auf Luca und Notifyer genauer eingehe. Notifir ist das Konzept ähm von.
Michael Weal, und ich wahrscheinlich noch anderen Autoren. Das sind die drei, die mir spontan einfallen, aber wir wollen natürlich alle,
erwähnen. Ich gucke mal ganz kurz ähm.
Wauter, oh, na, ist jetzt auf Twitter nur Wautal L. Ähm.
Schnell. Also jetzt kommen wir. Machen wir noch ganz kurz hier. Du kannst ja vielleicht ganz kurz.
Das ist im Prinzip so eine europaweit äh organisierte Zusammenkunft von Wissenschaftlern und Computerexperten und Pragmatikern, die auch schon erheblich am Konzept äh des ähm,
Exposure Notification, Fremdwalks gearbeitet haben, dass es letztlich die Idee, die Google und Apple aufgenommen und umgesetzt haben,
die kamen aus dieser Gruppe. Und später haben sie sich dann halt eben über diese spezifische Probleme,
Der Zusammenkünfte Gedanken gemacht, wie man denn dieselben Anforderungen und dieselben Leitideen der,
gesicherten Privatsphäre und nicht zentrale Speicherung et cetera wie man denn das übertragen könnte auf dieses Konzept. Und das haben wir vor einigen Monaten hier schon mal vorgestellt und es gibt auch, glaube ich, wenn ich das richtig sehe, in der
Schweiz eine App oder so.
Da kommen wir gleich drauf, da kommen wir gleich zu. Also uns kurz zusammenzufassen, EPFL Tromaler.
Carmela.
Dann äh Marcel Salaté, Eduard
Kennes Petterson von der ETH äh von der TÜD und äh Michael Wealf University College London. Ja, also das ist jetzt mal so, das sind Namen
Team äh und nicht nur bei den Universitäten, sondern eben auch bei den Autorinnen. Das sind Namen und wie gesagt, der größere Teil davon war auch an dem ähm.
DP3T schon beteiligt, nicht alle von denen äh haben auch das andere geschrieben. So ähm.
Diese beiden Konzepte reden wir jetzt mal ein bisschen genauer drüber. Zunächst möchte ich aber mal sagen, dass zugrunde liegende Probleme ist eben diese Anforderung.
Dass das die Gastronomiedaten nun mal erfassen muss und da gibt's zum Beispiel in den in UK haben die das dadurch gelöst, dass,
Venues gezwungen wurden, so einen QR-Code zu haben und du eine Ausnahme für die Papierkontect-Tracing-Regeln bekommen hast, wenn die App genutzt wurde?
Ähm und sie hatten bisher irgendwie ein paar hundert Auslösungen auch über für ihre Lösung, für die Gesundheitsämter,
haben da aber ein allgemeines Integrationsproblem und die Erfahrung in UK ist der Bluetooth-Teil, also der, das, was bei uns auch die CWA macht, ne?
Das hat insgesamt funktioniert das besser, ja? Äh in der Schweiz ist das ein bisschen dezentraler, die hatten ebenfalls erst so ein Zwang mit äh,
Adressen sammeln, dann wurde eine App namens gepusht und dann wurde,
als legitime Alternative in einigen Kantonen etabliert
und dieses social Pass, was ich vorher um, ne, als zentrales System mit Registrierung der Kundendaten und so äh schon ganz gut etabliert hatte. Das wurde dann von irgendwie so einer Bude gekauft, die Tickets verkauft. Also so,
äh äh als würde das jetzt irgendwie Eventim kaufen oder sowas, ne? Die haben dann gesagt, ach, das ist eine geile App, das das möchten wir gerne,
kaufen. Also so in der Schweiz haben sie halt quasi Ausnahmen für Digital-Apps gemacht.
So, jetzt kommen wir mal zu Luca. Ähm Luca.
Hat sich darüber Gedanken gemacht, wie kann man denn so ein Check-in.
Machen und ein paar Probleme lösen. Erstens, wir wollen nicht, dass die Leute Papier ausfüllen. Zweitens,
Wir wollen nicht, dass die Leute ähm,
Daten, einen Datenbestand, über welche Besucherinnen in Restaurants waren und erst recht nicht ihre Kontaktdaten überhaupt bei den Restaurants vorliegen.
Ne, also die sollen die Daten auch nicht einsehen können.
Und drittens, wir wollen halt die Übertragung an die Gesundheitsämter schneller machen. Und die Lösung für dieses Problem,
versuche das wie gesagt jetzt ein bisschen high Level zu äh beschreiben, nicht mit allen Details, ist, dass sie sagen, okay, deine du hast in dieser App, gibst du irgendwie deine Daten an.
Die sind in dieser App hinterlegt und wenn du jetzt in so einen äh in eine Location eincheckst, dann verschlüsselt du die Daten erstmal an das Gesundheitsamt,
Und diesen Satz verschlüsselter Daten an das Gesundheitsamt verschlüsselt du jetzt an die Location.
Und jetzt hat die Location quasi einen Satz Daten, den die Location nicht einsehen kann und der für die Location verschlüsselt, vorliegt. Und,
In dem Fall, dass jetzt diese Daten an das Gesundheitsamt gehen müssen, kann die Location, die nicht einsehen.
Und das Gesundheitsamt kann die auch nur einsehen, wenn die Location sie für das Gesundheitsamt entschlüsselt.
Ne, was erstmal keine blöde Idee ist, weil das bedeutet, dass die Location auf gar keinen Fall an deine Daten kommt
und das Gesundheitsamt nur dann, wenn die Location das auch tatsächlich freigibt, löst halt so nebenbei ein bisschen das Problem mit der ähm.
Wenn ihr zum Beispiel mal über die Polizei kommt und sagt, wir beschlagnahmen mal kurz hier ihre Papierzettel, weil wir gucken wollten, wer heute hier drin war, ne. Ähm,
Das ist also für dieses Problem nicht unbedingt die.
Dümmste Lösung, ne? Da haben wir zwanzig zwanzig sehr viel dümmere gesehen.
Kurz bevor wir angefangen haben unsere Sendung aufzuzeichnen, wurde äh interessanterweise äh ein wirklich,
peinlich. Also einfach nur peinlich. Peinlicher Back in dieser Luca-App äh öffentlich beschrieben. Auch da haben wir den äh Link in den Shownotes,
Und zwar sagt Luca immer, ja ja, du kannst von mir aus äh
auch falsche Daten da reinschreiben. Aber wenn wir die, wenn du das Setup machst, dann äh verifizieren wir ja deine Telefonnummer und das heißt, über deine Telefonnummer haben wir auf jeden Fall nochmal immer einen Draht zu dir.
Und.
Jetzt ist das so, dass die auf ihrer Website, wenn man sich da registriert, die Prüfung, ob du die Telefonnummer verifiziert hast, das machen die alles kleinseitig in Java Script.
Tim weiß, was das bedeutet, wenn das kleinseitig In Java Skript gemacht wird, heißt das, der Server verifiziert das nicht.
Und wenn du in dem Java Skript kurz rumfuchtelst und sagst, ja ja, die Telefonnummer ist verifiziert, keine Sorge, dann kannst du dich damit null acht fuffzehn siebenundvierzig elf anmelden.
Super. Voll sicher.
So und die die erzählen irgendwie, das hätte irgendjemand gereviewt oder gepennt testet oder sie hätten Security-Konzept, dann dürfen die natürlich solche ähm.
Also solche ähm sowas darf dir einfach nicht passieren, ne? Das lässt natürlich auch auf den.
Auf den Rest nicht unbedingt ähm hoffen. So, jetzt aber ne,
Punkt, den man ihm geben muss für das, was sich für grundsätzlich falsch halte. Dass man sich in Locations registriert und dass man dort,
persönlich identifizierbare Daten hinterlässt. Aber wenn das die Anforderung ist, dann haben Sie dafür eine,
elegantere Lösung als die meisten anderen. Es ist aber nicht so, als hätten nicht hätte sich diese Welt nicht seit ähm,
Anfang zwanzig zwanzig oder Anfang Restaurantöffnungen nicht auch bewegt. Es gibt eine ganze Reihe von,
Konkurrentinnen zu.
Luca, äh Recover ist ein Beispiel ähm und eine ganz, ganze Reihe von ähm.
Von Apps, die sich jetzt sogar zu einem Bündnis zusammengeschlossen haben und im Prinzip dagegen protestieren, dass äh hier diese Smudo App, die nun wirklich, also das muss man einfach sagen, seit drei Monaten ähm.
Sehr massiv beworben wird, ne? Also ich musste mich da schon vor drei Monaten in der Tagesschau äh in die in den Tagesthemen zu äußern und da wurden dann irgendwie Smudo und Tim Melzer aufgefahren, ne? Und da da wird richtig, richtig äh geschoben.
Und da fühlen sich natürlich andere ähm,
Apps durchaus äh benachteiligt, die vielleicht ähm mindestens genauso gute Konzepte haben, aber vielleicht keinen äh keine berühmte,
berühmtes Poster-Schalt, was dann irgendwie bei Markus Lanz eingeladen wird oder so.
Gibt's also die Initiative wir für Digitalisierung, wo sich jetzt äh eben eine Reihe von,
Konkurrentinnen zusammengeschlossen haben und hierfür ein äh für für eine Öffnung dieses Marktes,
sich engagieren. Es muss egal sein mit welcher App ein Betrieb digitale Kontaktdaten erfasst, wichtig ist, dass das Gesundheitsamt über über eine einheitliche, offene Schnittstelle darauf zugreifen kann, ne? Das ist quasi deren,
Argument, die sagen, okay, lasst bitte das Gesundheitsamt ein offenes Portal betreiben.
An das wir uns alle mit unterschiedlichen Apps anbinden können und dann ist äh äh dann, dann, dann ist hier dieser Markt.
Anders da, ne? Jetzt äh ist das natürlich mein, das ist eine, das ist jetzt kein kein, das ist ein Kampf von vielen Davids gegen einen äh Smudo Goliat, äh um um Geld, ne, denen geht's allen darum,
Geld mit der ganzen Sache zu verdienen, ne? Das darf man nicht vergessen, das sind alles keine
keine Altruistinnen und wenn Leute sich anschicken die Pandemie zu monetarisieren dann muss man ihnen eben auch mit einem gewissen Artwohn begegnen, das heißt nicht, dass das jetzt
unbedingt immer falsch ist. Die ähm Pandemie zu monetarisieren, ne, zum Beispiel so Impfstoffe sind relativ überzeugende Produkte.
Ja, ey, Tim, brauchst du Masken? Gegen eine geringe Provision.
Irre, hör mal auf, hör auf! Jetzt regen wir uns gerade noch über die Blockchain auf, jetzt denke ich auch noch an diese.
Epilog. Das machen wir, machen wir am Schluss.
Am Ende drüber auf. Ist in Ordnung. Eins, wir regen uns über eins nach dem anderen auf. So und schön in Ruhe. So Luca.
Luca-App. Riecover-App, genau. Und die die Annahme, um das vielleicht auch nochmal so ein bisschen aus einer anderen Perspektive zu machen,
all diese ganzen Apps drehen sich sozusagen im Wesentlichen da drum, das Problem zu lösen, was heißt Coronaschutzverordnung.
Nicht unbedingt jetzt so sehr das Problem Corona.
Danke, dass du das betonst. Tim, das ist genau der Punkt. Ja, das Problem heißt Corona-Schutzverordnung. Und ähm.
Jetzt muss man sich ja das so vorstellen, die Corona-Schutzverordnung kommt ja von dem gleichen Ministerium.
Wie letztendlich die Corona-Warn-App.
Und ich habe, das war auch das, was ich damals den Tagesthemen gesagt habe. Es ist schon sehr erstaunlich, dass die gleiche Bundesregierung, die diese Registrierungspflicht.
In den Restaurants vorschreibt.
Dir ähm eine Corona-Warn-App für viel Geld rausrückt.
Ihre Anforderungen da nicht kombiniert, ne? Also ihre eigene Anforderung nicht vielleicht sich mal anschickt zu erfüllen,
so wie es jetzt beispielsweise, ne, Großbritannien, da ist diese QR-Code-Funktionalität in die landeseigene Corona-Warn-App eingebaut worden und ähm die haben inzwischen.
Du weißt ja noch, dass wir hier darüber gelacht haben, wie Boris Johnson irgendwie fragt, äh Candy Gentleman name, One Country, with the functioning Chrounder One App und ähm,
dann kommt die Antwort. Großbritannien hat jetzt auch irgendwas über zwanzig Millionen und das ist gemessen an der Anzahl der Einwohnerinnen ein größerer Anteil als Deutschland.
Und der Pull-Faktor hier war.
Dass sie diese Gastroregistrierung da reingemacht haben. Weil das natürlich, ich meine, das ist etwas, was alle, wo alle sagen, oh ja, das ist gut. Ja, wollen wir auch haben. Ne? Und wenn du das machst, du hast ja in Deutschland jetzt auch eine Installationsbasis von über.
Sagen wir mal ein Viertel der Bevölkerung. Ähm auf dem auf dieser Installationsbasis kannst du ja aufbauen und dann gleichzeitig ergänzen, um
äh um diese weitere Funktion, dann wollen mehr Leute die App nutzen, dann hast du bei der Bluetooth-Funktionalität auch nochmal einen höheren äh Wirksamkeitsgrad, ne. Kannste, könntest du machen.
Und weißt du, was der Kick ist? Machen die auch. Das machen die auch und das wird der der Plan ist, dass Mitte, Mitte, Mitte ähm,
äh wie heißt der Monat? April, Mitte April, äh ungefähr zu releasen. So, trotzdem.
Obwohl die quasi grade dabei sind eine Funktionalität in ihre Corona-Warn-App einzubauen, pushen die jetzt Luca. Wahrscheinlich, weil sie irgendwie einen geilen Deal mit Luca haben.
Und Luca noch die Restmasken gekauft hat oder so, ne? Also diese Skurrilität überhaupt dir mal dir mal vor Augen zu führen, ne? Ich meine, eine.
Basis eine eine Erfassung auf Basis von hab ich gefordert seit also ich weiß eh mein Oktober letzten Jahres,
da habe ich äh das habe ich hier in Lokbuch Netzpolitik gesagt, da habe ich einen äh Artikel zugeschrieben in meinem Blog, da habe ich einen Artikel auf heise zugeschrieben und habe,
Ja, sechzehnter Oktober und habe dafür getrommelt, ne, was äh ein sinnvolles System wäre und das das Interessante war, dass,
ich glaube am gleichen Tag, aber ich wusste es wirklich nicht,
System in sauber ausformuliert dann eben als von den Profis vorgestellt wurde, ne? Ich hatte das irgendwie grob plump so so ungefähr könnte man's machen und
am gleichen Tag oder einen Tag später haben die einen vollständiges Whitepaper, wo es zu Ende gedacht war, was ich nur angedacht habe, äh rausgehauen.
Ähm.
Jetzt hat in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern hat zum Beispiel für vierhundertvierzigtausend Euro eine Luka-Lizenz gekauft, was äh wo jetzt auch keiner genau weiß, was das bedeutet, aber ich vermute, dass sie damit meinen.
Dass dann eben ja für für Einrichtungen in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern die Nutzung der App dann eben kostenlos sein wird, weil die halten natürlich auch die Hand auf dafür.
So. Jetzt habe ich ganz viel von gesprochen. Jetzt erkläre ich. Oder ist noch was zu Luca zu sagen?
Ähm,
sicherlich im Nachgang. Ähm ich denke, das ist jetzt erst mal klar geworden, warum sich diese Kategorie von Apps kümmert so und welche Rolle Luca da derzeit so spielt und es ist halt auch so, dass sie halt in irgendeiner Form jetzt schon so den Fuß in der Tür haben.
Mindestens in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, in Berlin wird auch schon darüber übersiniert, also es geistert so diese Idee äh herum, dass das ja irgendwie geil wäre,
wenn man da jetzt zu einer Lösung findet. Die Frage ist natürlich auch äh ist das eigentlich eine Lösung? Weil,
letztlich reden wir hier von einer Informationsvermittlung an Gesundheitsämter, die,
nicht gerade unbedingt damit geglänzt haben, besonders viele Ressourcen frei zu haben und diese Kontaktverfolgung äh bei dem Stand der Pandemie derzeit besonders effizient zu lösen. Letztlich will man ja Leute warnen.
Corona-Warn-App ist halt ein Ansatz,
Ist jetzt ein anderer Ansatz, während sich die CBA halt um die Nähe kümmert, weil das war ja auch das, was am Anfang alle dachten. Oh, das wird irgendwie von Mensch zu Mensch übertragen,
wenn man da zu nah dran ist, dann springt das irgendwie über. Später kam dann irgendwie immer klarer heraus, ja, stimmt schon, auch irgendwie, aber das sehr viel größere Probleme sind Aerosole und,
es ist generell ein Problem, sich vor allem längere Zeit im selben Raum mit irgendjemand aufzuhalten, aber da spielen dann diese ominösen anderthalb Meter
eigentlich nicht mehr jetzt so die entscheidende Rolle. Es ist sehr viel wichtiger festzustellen, wer war jetzt mit mir über einen bestimmten Zeitraum mehr oder weniger am selben Ort? Selbst wenn ich jetzt nicht
neben dieser Person gestanden habe und das ist eben das andere Problem, was Crowd Notifyer versucht, jetzt zu lösen.
Ich habe mich übrigens auch mit äh Umgang nochmal anzuknüpfen äh Gesundheitsamt, zwei Beispiele. Ich habe mich vor kurzem mit einer vom Gesundheitsamt unterhalten
und hab ihr folgendes Folgendes geschildert und zwar gastronomische Einrichtung,
handelt sich um ein Restaurant und dieses in diesem Restaurant waren äh sechs Leute von der Belegschaft hatten Corona,
ja? Und die haben auch äh kurz vor ihrer Testung noch dort gearbeitet. Ähm wo du dir denkst, oh
oh Gott, Alptraum, ne? Jetzt wird das äh Restaurant geschlossen und Gesundheitsamt reitet ein und was nicht alles, ne?
Äh die Listen lagen schon bereit. Äh so bei dem Gesundheitsamt angerufen, haben gesagt, so wir haben die Listen hier, ne? Wie können wir euch die denn jetzt übergeben? Was machen wir denn jetzt hier, ne? Und Gesundheitsamt sagt, wie wollen wir überhaupt nicht haben?
Das sind ja alles keine äh Kontakte ersten Grades, weil ihre äh Kellner, die sind ja höchstens mal ein Minütchen am Tisch und außerdem haben die ja was in dem Restaurant auch richtig war, äh zustimmt war.
Masken getragen. Und da haben die, äh obwohl in der, also wirklich an mehreren Stellen in einem Restaurant auch an relevanten Stellen infizierte Personen gearbeitet haben, den Gästen überhaupt nicht Bescheid gesagt. So,
Ich will jetzt gar nicht sagen, dass das falsch war vom Gesundheitsamt, ähm es hat mich persönlich überrascht und äh das
oder Eigner des Restaurants auch. Ähm aber als sich das der
ähm Personen vom Gesundheitsamt erzählt habe, sagte sie, ja natürlich nicht, absoluter Unsinn, das ganze Restaurant jetzt irgendwie in Quarantäne zu schicken oder da die Gäste zu nerven, weil natürlich eigentlich eben diese primäre und die Hochrisikokontakte das sind
wo wir eigentlich hinterher sind, ne? Und das genau macht ja die Corona-Warn-App eben sehr viel schneller und effizienter als ein Gesundheitsamt. Also das Problem ist eigentlich überhaupt diese Erfassung.
Solange du die Vorgabe einer namentlichen Erfassung hast, kannst du die aber auch nicht in die Corona-Warn-App einbauen, weil die Corona-Warnapp ja ein anonymes System ist
und es
sowohl von Apple, Google als auch kannst du sofort mit Ulrich Kälber drüber sprechen im Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragter und auch mit jedem UI oder UXler, ne, in die Corona-Warn-App kannst du nicht den Leuten sagen, hier ist eine anonyme App, trag mal deinen Namen rein ein
ne, das geht einfach nicht. Ähm steht, steht, steht nicht zur Debatte. Entsprechend wirbt Luca,
geil, weil ihr ja eh 'ne zweite App braucht, weil ihr ja unbedingt darauf besteht Namen eh darauf besteht Namen zu erfassen, empfehlt doch bitte in der Corona-Warn-App unsere App
Ja, macht man, können wir noch ein bisschen mehr Werbung haben, ähm damit wir den Teil äh auch noch haben. Sie
werben auch, dass sie den Gesundheitsämtern eben äh Zeit ersparen, indem sie A äh die Kontaktverfolgung,
Übertragung vereinheitlichen und damit auch eine einheitliche Datenbasis für alle hätten, ne?
Und diese könnte zum Beispiel auch Schicht oder Sitzpläne in,
ähm äh bei Bereichsunterteilungen beinhalten, ne? Hast du ein Restaurant mit zwei Sälen oder sagst du irgendwie, welche Schicht hat wann gearbeitet, ne, oder wer hat an welchem Tisch gesessen?
Schock,
hast du plötzlich eine namentliche Registrierung, wer wann, in welchem Restaurant war? Du siehst ja auch bei der an der Reihenfolge, wie die Leute in Luca einchecken, dass sie da zusammen waren. Und jetzt erfasst du auf einmal, zumindest am Ende für die staatliche Stelle,
Vorname, Nachname, Telefonnummer, Zusatzinformation und,
zumindest die zeitliche Korrelation oder wenn deine Anbieterin sogar noch ein Tischplan hinterlegt, wer gemeinsam am Tisch gesessen hat. Ja, so Sachen, die vielleicht gar nicht so,
äh im Interesse der Nutzerinnen sind, ne. Okay, kommen wir zu.
Ist die Erfassungseinheit und Tim, du hast es ja gerade schon gesagt, da geht's wieder nicht darum,
der Verordnung genüge zu tun, die sich ja schon als sperrig und nicht zielführend genug erwiesen hat, sondern es geht,
Darum weder das Problem schnell zu lösen,
Und da ist dieser Datentyp, was ich damals auch in der Sendung äh schon äh gesagt habe, was du eigentlich messen möchtest, sind Zusammenkünfte. Und das sind keine Locations. Das sind keine Venues, das sind keine Orte, sondern das ist,
Menschen waren zusammen. Die können ja auch zusammen in der Bahn gesessen haben. Und.
Insbesonder oder besonders verständlich wird das, wenn du dir darüber Gedanken machst, dass diese Zusammenkunft vielleicht nicht,
in einem Restaurant oder an einer Venue stattgefunden hat, also irgendein Veranstaltungsort, sondern in der Kirche,
in einer Synagoge, in einer Moschee, in irgendein Vereinsheim, ähm irgendwelche Dinge, die eben nicht eine Location sind, sondern ja, eine Gruppe, eine Zusammenkunft,
Und,
spätestens dann möchtest du nicht nur Privatsphäre für die Nutzerinnen haben oder die Teilnehmerinnen der Zusammenkunft, sondern du möchtest auch für,
die Zusammenkunft selber eine Privacy haben. Das hat Luca nicht. Bei Luca ist jeder Ort. Fest registriert, ne? Und,
damit kommen natürlich dann auch,
entsprechende Potentiale, was irgendwie, ne, oder es ist aber die Corona-Bar, da gehe ich nicht mehr hin oder sowas, ne. Und denke mal an Hochzeiten und so weiter.
Du willst eigentlich einen maximalen Schutz dafür haben, dass die Daten überhaupt ausgenutzt werden können? Und wenn du das machst,
Vom Verwendungszweck so einschränkst, dann wird das einfach auch verschwinden, wenn man es nicht mehr braucht.
Wenn du daran denkst, dass andere, die namentlich erfassen, auf einmal von irgendwelchen schweizer Ticketverkäuferbuden gekauft werden, die kaufen nichts ohne finanzielles Interesse.
Und hier ist eben bei ähm,
bei der, bei der Ansatz, dass im Prinzip jede Person so viele Zusammenkünfte würfeln kann, wie sie will, die Leute, die daran teilnehmen, scannen dann eben,
ähm die den QR-Code und in dem Moment ist wie bei der Corona-Warn-App, die diese Informationen nur,
bei den Teilnehmerinnen oder den Anwesenden auf den Geräten. Und wenn du jetzt als einzelne Person.
Irgendwie diese also eine Notification auslöst, dann kannst du quasi deine Zusammenkünfte auswählen und sagen, okay, die möchte ich auch warnen.
Die Information, die aber dafür veröffentlicht wird, dass du warnst, ist für alle, die nicht da waren, komplett ohne ähm Bedeutung
Ja, also da wird einfach ein Court veröffentlicht und das ist jetzt quasi, ne, der geheime Auslöser für alle, die da waren, die wissen, oh, wenn das kommt, dann weiß ich Bescheid. Hier,
Problem in dieser Situation. Und das löst potentiell auch,
Das Problem, dass die Leute das selber bewerten können. Wenn du jetzt mit wenn du über eine Location triggerst, ähm,
wollen diese Leute vom Gesundheitsamt auch lieber eben selber entscheiden, ja? Zum Beispiel zu sagen, okay, welche willst du informieren, willst du alle informieren oder nicht? Und.
Dieses, da kannst du's schnell machen, erstens die Auswahl und zweitens auch das Auslösen, weil eben die Zusammenkunft erfasst wird und die Leute das selber äh machen können.
Und da denke ich ähm wenn man jetzt mal daran denkt, dass.
So wir zwanzig einundzwanzig noch schön in der in der Pandemie hängen werden und so etwas brauchen werden, scheint es mir dann doch sinnvoller, solche Systeme so anonym wie möglich zu machen. Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Leute, die,
ähm,
viel Geld in QR-Code basierte Systeme am Check-In investieren. Nicht sich darüber Gedanken machen, wie das Spiel zwanzig zweiundzwanzig weitergeht.
Wenn vielleicht dann doch mal alle geimpft sind,
und das hier, diese Schweizer Bruder, schon von so einem Ticketverkäufer gekauft wurde, das deutet ja schon in die richtige Richtung. Und da würde ich mich dann doch sehr viel besser fühlen mit einem.
Vollständig anonym System, dass auch in meiner äh Privat,
in meinem Privatzusammenkünften, den Hochzeiten, den Synagogen, Moscheen, Kirchen und so weiter, die ich besuche anwendbar ist, ohne eine zentrale Datensammlung.
Du könntest sogar,
geheimes Treffen machen, um Einbruch zu planen in der Bank und trotzdem problemlos darüber auslösen, weil niemand weiß, was zweckt dieses Treffens war, niemand weiß, wie viele Leute daran teilgenommen haben, wann das war.
Ja, wir wir haben zwanzig Minuten unten im Tresorraum geschweißt. Das war leider ein bisschen zu lange, Tim, ne? Ja, kannst du machen. So, das ist.
Ja, Corona-Schutz auch für Knackis.
Ja, gerade die äh auf engstem Raum zwanzig Jahre.
Sind jetzt auch safe.
Ja und das ist, ne, der Grund, warum man solche, ja, Alu, Hutanforderungen definiert, ist, um Geschäftsmodelle zu zerstören, um den Verwendungszweck einzuschränken.
Um wirkliche Privacy zu schaffen. Und das Interessante ist tatsächlich auch also die Leute sagen immer, sie wollen ähm.
Es ist kein Problem, wenn ihre Daten erfasst werden,
ne? Aber wenn sie dann wirklich danach gefragt werden, geben sie falsche Daten an. Das ist ja das, was äh ne, also bei der gastronomischen Erfassung eben das Ergebnis war. Wenn du da mal in die Listen guckst, das ist unglaublich, was Donald Duck da irgendwie konsumiert, ne. Da geht ein und aus.
Na ja. So jetzt Luca.
Na ja, also kommt dahin. Die haben jetzt halt irgendwie den Joker gezogen, irgendwie Smudo sich vor den Karren spannen zu können, der macht da auch der macht da richtig Werbung für, der hat natürlich
Also ist ja, sagen wir mal bisher nicht als Experte für IT-Sicherheit oder Datenschutz irgendwo äh auffällig geworden. Äh dafür macht er das ganz gut.
Kann aber natürlich auch zum Beispiel die Code-Basis nicht beurteilen und sieht dann eben ähm,
Ja, dass sie jetzt noch nicht mal die Verifikation der Telefonnummer, was jetzt wirklich, also dass du Verifikation immer serverseitig machen muss, ne. Wenn jemand.
Können das übrigens auch nicht, ne? Weil ist ja nicht Open Source.
Ja, da bin ich aber auch vorsichtig mit dem Open-Source-Argument, weil.
In der Öffentlichkeit wird Open Source immer so als die Lösung aller Probleme verstanden. Und Open Source ist nicht,
Die hinreichende Bedingung, es ist die notwendige Bedingung, damit sie's überhaupt jemand angucken kann.
Und ne, ist die Grundvoraussetzung, aber nicht die hinreichende Erfüllung aller Anforderungen. Und na ja,
Das war natürlich klar, dass diese Luca Leute sich,
nicht lange nehmen lassen, irgendwann stolz anzukündigen, yo, wir machen jetzt Open Saurs und dann hast du auch direkt, sage ich mal, die,
die Leute, die sich dann auch nicht zu schade sind da vor den, vor dem, sich vor den Karren spannen zu lassen und zu jubeln und das als ihren Erfolg zu feiern, dass jetzt Luca Open Source wird. Das ist überhaupt nicht das Problem.
Dass dadurch wird es nicht besser oder schlechter. Ähm.
Wir haben da mal so ein bisschen mit den APIs gespielt, so leicht ist bisschen Hochstapelerei ist da schon so hinter, bisher sind da, sage ich mal, eine eine niedrige, zweistellige Anzahl Gesundheitsämter tatsächlich registriert,
dreihundertachtzig gibt's in Deutschland. Die Anbindung der Gesundheitsämter wird natürlich die eine Kernherausforderung, weil die müssen ja alle mit Kryptomaterial versorgt werden.
Dreihundertachtzig, vierhundert Gesundheitsämter oder sowas in Deutschland, die müssen alle irgendwie einen Schlüsselmaterial haben, um ihre Daten dann da zu entschlüsseln.
Weiterer Punkt ist, dadurch, dass du den Venues irgendwie auch nochmal Kryptomaterial gibst, musst du natürlich auch dafür sorgen, dass die,
ähm dass die dieses Schlüsselmaterial ordentlich aufbewahren. Und sagen wir mal so, bei Leuten die Verschlüsse, bei Dienstanbietern, die verschlüsseln.
Die machen sich dann auch irgendwann immer Gedanken, hör mal, wann machen wir eigentlich, wenn jemand da den Schlüssel verliert und man nicht an die Daten kommen kann, dann wären wir ja nachher dran.
Und da passiert dann in der Regel so noch irgendeine elegante Lösung, wie man vielleicht dann doch an die Daten kommt.
So zum Beispiel könnte sich ja äh Luca selber auch nochmal als Gesundheitsamt registrieren und hätte dann schon mal,
im Zweifelsfall Zugriff auf die Daten, ne? Und dann könnte man,
einen Schlüsselwiederherstellungsmechanismus für die Kundinnen machen, damit nicht, dass sie nachher einen neuen Computer haben oder ihren Browser,
deinstallieren und den Schlüssel nicht mehr haben und um die Daten zu entschlüsseln, ne? Und da kommen dann rucki zucki ähm nochmal äh so Lösungen mit hinzu. Für,
Realweltprobleme bei verschlüsselten Daten. Und da, ja, präferiere ich natürlich dann schon eigentlich einen Ansatz, was du nicht brauchst, brauchst du auch nicht zu erfassen. Aber das Problem heißt eben,
Coronaverordnung und nicht nicht mehr und nicht weniger.
Und dich könnte man ja auch ändern.
Das wäre sehr sinnvoll, die zu ändern, ja. Das wäre sehr sinnvoll.
Also ich halte es für, na ja, also irgendwie Adressen zu erfassen. Hm,
Das hat uns nix gebracht. Das Einzige, was ich jetzt eigentlich so lustig finde, da muss ich wirklich sagen, da bin ich so ein bisschen äh tang in, ne.
Sowie der Smudo sich da gerade feiern lässt, ne? Und irgendwie als der Weiße Ritter mit seiner App da ankommt, ne? Boah, was werden die denn fertig machen, wenn die vierte Welle kommt?
Fertig machen, dass der Smudo, der Smudo hat gesagt, mit Luca wird alles gut.
Und jetzt sitzen wir hier und sitzen wieder im Lockdown. Da bin ich mir eigentlich nicht,
wenn ich das wird auf jeden Fall lustig. Also dieses diese Solution Nissan und diese Heilskraft,
Leute irgendwie,
von Apps erwarten, ne. Die gleichen Leute, die sagen, wat, ich impfe mich doch nicht mit Astra Seneker erwarten dann halt, dass die Corona-Warn-App irgendwie so ein, so ein Schutzschild um sie
macht oder dass Luca irgendein Schutzschild um sie machen würde. Das ist schon, das sind schwierige Zeiten, Tim.
Ja, also die Geschichte der Corona-Wanne bisher eine Geschichte der Missverständnisse und irgendwie.
Das ist sehr gut gestartet. Es ist auch alles, was wert. Es gibt ja viel Diskussion darüber, wie viel das gekostet hat und so weiter. Ne, das kennen wir ja alles, ne. Und das kann man jetzt auf alles Mögliche hochrechnen.
Pavel hat mal schön ausgerechnet, was ja jetzt nicht im Detail nachvollziehen, aber so im Wesentlichen muss man einfach sagen, jeder einzelne.
Einzelne Infizierte in Deutschland. Und ich rede gar nicht mal von schweren Fällen jetzt, sondern irgendwie jede Infektion selber,
Quarantäne nach sich zieht, die Arbeitsausfall hat und so weiter, schafft,
volkswirtschaftlichen Schaden. Das ist alles Geld am Ende, was nicht da ist oder bezahlt werden muss oder beides. Und insofern kann man schon davon ausgehen,
auch die Corona-Warn-App ähm in ihrer aktuellen Form und Ausprägung schon auch eine ganze Menge Geld gespart hat,
Weil da sind viele Leute gewarnt worden. Vielleicht nicht alle möglichen, es hat auch nicht unbedingt die komplette Ausbreitung dieser Pandemie äh gestoppt, aber sie hat sie sicherlich an manchen Stellen zurückgehalten und dann ist das auch schon was wert.
Es ist halt am Anfang zurecht auch gefeiert worden,
dieses Modell, was ja eigentlich außergewöhnlich war und so auch nur durch diese spezielle politische Konstellation zustande kommen konnte,
letztlich muss man auch sagen, auch durch den Druck von Google und Apple, die einfach gesagt haben, was anderes kommt uns hier nicht auf ihr Telefon. Ähm sodass es dann halt so gemacht wurde und dass es dann eben auch ein Stück weit wirklich äh sehr gut gemacht wurde und das Endergebnis ist ja nicht schlecht.
Nur was da nicht verstanden wurde, ist,
dass es damit nicht getan ist, einerseits und andererseits, dass man dranbleiben muss, das hat eine Weile gedauert, bis das wieder sofort aufgenommen hat und außerdem,
ist auch überhaupt und ist niemand auf so richtig auf die Idee gekommen, was für eine einmalige Gelegenheit das ist, so ein so ein One-Stop-Shop,
Corona zu machen.
Und ich meine jetzt nicht, dass da alle Sachen reingeschoben werden müssen. Aber das ist jetzt irgendwie fast ein Jahr gedauert, bis da mal die aktuellen RKI-Zahlen angezeigt werden,
ja? Oder dass die App auch immer noch nicht in der Lage ist, einem einfach mal grade zu sagen, hier,
Das ist jetzt grade die gültigen Regeln. Ja, wäre ja mal gar nicht so schlecht, dass man nicht stundenlang äh auf irgendwelchen Tagesspiegel
FAZ-Seiten rumsurfen, muss sich dumm und duselig sucht, um irgendwie versuchen, klar mal rauszubekommen, was sind denn jetzt eigentlich gerade die Einschränkungen? Was darf ich denn nicht.
Oder was ist geboten oder was worauf soll ich achten oder so,
man hat es einfach nicht genutzt so und man hat's jetzt auch nicht für diese Sache genutzt, zumindest noch nicht. Und man hat sich überhaupt auch relativ wenig Gedanken darüber gemacht,
wie man da ein kluges Marketing machen kann. Naja, da haben sie halt so einen, so ein Badge auf irgendwelche Fußball Trikots in der Bundesliga drauf genäht, ein paar Plakate aufgehängt,
und so ein bisschen damit gewedelt, jetzt Corona-Wandebitz, alles gut. Und dann war das halt irgendwie weg. Aber das so wirklich so als so ein strategisches Essen zu begreifen und zu sagen so, wir denken darüber nach
Was die Leute dazu bringen könnte, das Ding wirklich als als hilfreiches Werkzeug zu akzeptieren? Ja oder andere zu setzen
habe irgendwie vor ein paar Tagen gewitzelt, hat sich auch rausgestellt, das gibt's wohl irgendwo im Gitarb auch schon als Vorschlag und ich finde, ehrlich gesagt, den Gedanken immer noch nicht so abwegig so. Warum wird in der Corona-Warn-App nicht jede Woche zehntausend Euro verlost?
Zehntausend Euro pro Woche ist im Rahmen unserer Ausgaben ein Scheiß. So und du sagst einfach, wenn du die Kack-App installierst, jede Woche bei irgendeinem Plims hoch, wo du sagst, du hast zehntausend Euro gewonnen.
Das Problem ist, bei denen wo es plümpt und sagt, du hast nicht zehntausend Euro gewonnen, sondern eine rote Corona-Warn-App. Das das gibt auf jeden Fall nochmal einen ganz anderen Thrill, wenn du von dem Ding eine Push-Notification kriegst.
Ja, du kannst auch eine positive Erwartung haben. So achtest zumindest mehr drauf.
Kriegst du auch gleich noch die die Telefonnummer von deiner lokalen Bild-Zeitungsredaktion, kannst gleich anrufen und erzählen, wie geil das war, damit da schön der ganze Boulevard drüber macht.
Ihr wollt es doch eh und dann weißt du dann stürzen sich alle drauf, weil es sind alles
so ein Volk von so Schnäppchenjägern und Billig und ich und ich und ich. Immer wenn ich so auf Clubhaus auch so Diskussionen gehört habe und dann so Leute äh sich gemeldet haben und gefragt wurden, ja warum installierst du die nicht? Da kommt dann immer so was wie.
Ja, mir bringt das nichts. Und ich brauche das nicht und ich habe nichts davon. Ich meine, denke so, Leute.
Doch du hast was davon, wenn weil alle was davon haben, irgendwie kollektiv Gesellschaft, Gemeinschaft irgendwie, das ist aber so ein
die Leute denken einfach nicht so. Es ist ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich will, ich brauche, ich will nicht, ich will nicht,
nicht dürfen. Ich will tun können, ich will zum Friseur, ich will das,
alle wissen, was sie wollen.
Muss das klären.
Und Smudo soll das jetzt mal klarmachen,
So und das ist und dann sage ich halt so, okay, gut, wenn das die Realität ist, dann denken wir da halt so rum und dann gibt's einfach Lotto. Ja, dann ist das irgendwie bringt's mehr, als jetzt im äh im normalen Sechs aus neunundvierzig zu spielen.
Speist da einfach Kohle rein.
Die verbrennen wir sowieso die ganze Zeit. Und wenn das irgendwie, also es klingt absurd, ne? Aber du weißt auch, was passieren würde. Wenn wir das machen, dann werden nächste Woche, hätten zwanzig Millionen Leute zusätzlich das installiert.
Weil da gibt's dann was, da gibt's dann mal was. Die Hoffnung, Geld zu verdienen.
Es ist also du du hast recht, das also die Corona-Warn-App haben sie ja sauber gebaut.
Du kannst eben nicht eine App einmal bauen und dann sagen, du bist damit fertig. Du musst A, was sie sehr, was sie sehr lange auch sehr,
Übel versemmelt haben, waren die ähm Anbindungen drumherum, ne? Testzentren und so weiter, wobei man auch mal zumindest sagen muss,
dass das auch etwas,
Gutes ist, dass sie das überhaupt hat. In vielen anderen Ländern hast du das nicht, dass die App dir auch hier in einem sauberen, anonymen Modell, dein Testergebnis vermitteln kann und so, ne? Das sind das ist auch, hm, ne, du musst.
Zum Feature.
Ist ein Feature, kann man, könnte man stolz drauf sein, könnte man bewerben,
ne? Stattdessen äh würgen sie das irgendwie kaputt, lassen sich von den Laboren irgendwie die Schnittstellen kaputt nörgeln, ähm zwingen nicht die Labore, sich daran ordentlich anzubinden,
ähm.
Und äh unterstützen auch nicht, nicht offenbar nicht ausreichend dazu, ne? Wir haben ja darüber äh gesprochen, dann, wie du schon sagst,
die App mit halbwegs sinnvollen Werten
oder funktionell äh äh Daten oder Funktionalitäten zu erweitern. Alles so lieblos, ja, so kaputt
So warmer schön. Ich habe in der Bundestagsanhörung letzte Woche auch gesagt, so da hattet ihr einmal nicht genug Zeit, das zu verkacken. Und siehe da, da ist das auf einmal gelungen.
Ne? Kaum gibst du denen Zeit, das zu verkacken, wenn die App erst mal da ist, dann musst du da kannst du dann dann brauchst du nicht lange warten, bis die bis die dann irgendwie kaputt sitzen, ne.
Und, und, und so, so Gate-Keeper, äh technologische Gate-Kepper, die wissen, was sie tun. Das hilft auch.
Ja und dann hast du, äh weißt du und jetzt sitz, jetzt sitzen die gleichen Leute da und sagen, ja,
Nee, jetzt Luca. Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt treiben wir die Smudo-Sau durchs Dorf. Der ist cool. Der ist nämlich cool, der jungen Leute, die mögen den. So, also die.
Der hat auch, der hat auch mehrere Blockchains bei sich zu Hause in der Garage. Ist so geil.
Es ist, also es ist einfach, ne, so Leute mit Digitalkompetenz. Wir haben die ja in der Opposition,
die dann vielleicht mal sagen würden, alles klar oder äh ähm die vielleicht auch einfach mal was anderes,
machen können in der Kommunikation über eine über digitale Ansätze zur Pandemiebekämpfung,
sagen, das löst jetzt alle Probleme.
Oder das ist der totale Scheiß, wir wollen was Neues, ja, die vielleicht einfach mal sinnvoller,
aufbauen, aber für diese auch irgendwie halbwegs ordentlich einstehen und sagen, so hier so und so sieht das aus äh und das kann es und das kann es nicht, ja? Stattdessen äh ist es jetzt irgendwie so,
Ja hier der Smudo, der hatte zweimal verschlüsselt, zweimal und unten Impfpasser, fünf Blockchain. So, jetzt kommen jetzt geht das aber rund hier, ey. Jetzt können wir alle nochmal Karussell fahren. Äh wie Affi hat nicht geklappt. Ja, Smudo, was war das denn?
Ne, also das ist so man und das ist so sehenden Auges, ne. Die,
vor drei, vier Wochen oder wann auch immer, ich weiß ja nicht, Zeit habe ich, Zeit kenne ich ja nicht mehr. Als es losging mit der B eins eins sieben, haben die Leute die Kurven gemalt und haben gesagt, so so werden sich die
Zahlen entwickeln, ne? Und haben alle gesagt, Quatsch, Alter, locker, bleiben, locker bleiben. Und jetzt, jetzt siehst du,
wie wie das sowieso zum Ausmalen, ne. Jeden Tag malt einer die Fläche weiter aus und man wundert sich, ey krass, woher hat,
jemand das vor vier Wochen schon gemalt? Woher wusste das jemand? Oh.
Dieses Quiz, wo man da irgendwie immer die Buchstaben kaufen muss, genau. Da steht ist auch schon echt fast jeder Buchstabe zu.
Muss sie kaufen, glaube ich. Ich glaube, Fokale muss sie kaufen, Konsonanten.
Ja
Mit mit Buchstaben kennt sich da auch aus. Hm? CC ist was ich drehe. CWA.
Ich kenne sogar die echte Zeile. THC, OCB ist, was ich drehe. Ich weiß aber nicht, was das bedeuten soll.
Gut.
Ja, sind wir durch, ne? Also, Luca, App, ja. Fazit, ähm.
Du hast Luca konzentriert sich auf Gastronomie und Locations,
was du eigentlich haben willst, sind Versammlungen im Allgemeinen und dieses Datenmodell, was Luca da hat, ist dafür nicht unbedingt
geeignet mit der zentralen Erfassung. Das ist ja eines, was du was du eigentlich nicht haben möchtest. Dann Barrierefreiheit haben wir irgendwie in, habe ich, glaube ich, bei euch auf Clubhaus auch gehört, dass da die Leute jetzt nicht so.
Ähm von begeistert waren, auf Clubhaus spricht man ja äh überproportional oft auch mal über Barrierefreiheit, was ich sehr gut finde, weil die App natürlich ähm sehr auf Blinde attraktiv ist,
die dann äh gibt da sehr interessante Einblicke immer in die Erfahrungswelt,
Also was? Man stellt sich barrierefreiheit so einfach vor, ne? Aber das ist ja wirklich und es ist eigentlich auch einfach, wenn du weißt, was du machen musst
und wenn du hörst, was äh eine Barriere darstellt und was nicht. Aber das musst du eben von den Leuten erklären lassen, die diese Barrieren wahrnehmen können. Ähm,
die Anbindung an die Gesundheitsämter, ich fürchte, das ist halt eine.
Ich ich habe einfach keine Hoffnung in diese ganzen Gesundheitsamtsachen. Eine Äpfel alles wäre grundsätzlich äh wünschenswert mit einer Installationsbasis von über ein paar Millionen wäre, dass die Corona-Warn-App,
Notify wäre das, was man da gerne drin hätte. Ähm und,
das wäre eine elegante und schnelle Lösung. Jetzt muss ich noch einen kleinen Disclaimer vorwegsetzen. Ich,
bisher nur lese, dass SAP äh etwas baut, was mit QR-Codes funktioniert und was anonym sein soll.
Die Frage ist aber, inwiefern das wirklich sein wird? Ne, also man muss sich hier immer fragen.
Was ist die Messeinheit? Ist sie eine Location? Oder ist sie die Zusammenkunft? Und,
ich ne, Zusammenkunft, diesen Begriff habe ich im deutschsprachigen Bereich so ein bisschen geprägt, als wir darüber im Podcast gesprochen haben
Und ich denke, Zusammenkunft ist die einzige richtige Einheit. Weil, ich meine, gerade die fantastischen vier, ich weiß nicht, was die erwarten,
Wie viele Gäste die ähm,
ihren Konzerten haben werden, ne? Aber die, das ist ja quasi auch das Interesse, mit dem sie da werben, dass sie sagen, wir würden auch ganz gerne nochmal auftreten. Und.
Denke tatsächlich, dass da also bei jetzt,
da da werden sie mit irgendeiner Luca-App auch nicht besonders weit kommen. Es sei denn, die clustern dann da irgendwie die die Leute in in dem ich weiß nicht, ob's oder vielleicht gibt's da auch gar keine Stehplätze mehr bei fantastischen vier Konzernen, ich weiß es nicht. Aber.
Sie haben nur noch Sitzplätze oder was? Oh Gott.
Ähm nein, nein, das war auch ein Scherz.
Und ne, Mut mal eine elegante Lösung zu machen, Mut auch einfach mal was schnelles zu machen und die Technologien auszureizen.
Jetzt irgendwie und hier noch eine zentrale Datenbank und hier noch eine Gesundheitsamt-Anbindung und so. Allerdings,
so viel sei gesagt, ich halte, ne, das haben wir jetzt oft genug betont, diese Erfassung mit Namen und so in der Gastronomie halte ich für einfach nicht zielführend, aber für diese Anforderung scheint Luca,
eine halbwegs elegante Lösung zu sein und zwar so von konzeptionell her allem überlegen was ich zwanzig zwanzig gesehen habe aber nicht notwendigerweise den Konkurrentinnen überlegen.
Natürlich jetzt bald ist es das, weil wenn sie jetzt schon mal vierhundertvierzigtausend Euro von Mecklenburg-Vorpommern haben, das können sie ja dann auch noch ein bisschen in Produktpflege,
investieren, vielleicht führen sie ja sogar mal serverseitige Verifikationen,
ein für die Daten, die da irgendjemand eingibt. Bis dahin können wir uns alle noch schön mit falschen Nummern registrieren und dann ist auch nicht schlimm,
wenn wir irgendwo zu Luca verpflichtet werden, weil wir dann weiterhin Donald Duck mit null acht fuffzehn siebenundvierzig elf registrieren können.
Ton halt ey. Immer in der Pizzeria.
Über die Maskennummer wollten wir uns noch aufregen, Tim.
Sind wir jetzt eigentlich schon am Ende der Sendung oder was? Okay.
Bis morgen, ah, nee, bis Freitagabend müssen die CDU-Abgeordneten alle unterschreiben, dass sie sich nicht ähm an der Pandemie bereichert haben. Und da gibt's so herrlich überspezifische Dementi, das ist echt schön. Da kannst du dich jetzt schon drauf freuen.
Ja, ich meine, ist ja auch irgendwie jetzt nicht besonders überraschend, ne, dass sie sich irgendwie seit Jahrzehnten dagegen wehren, das deutsche Parlament dann vielleicht auch mal so nach,
internationalen Korruptionsstandards äh mit entsprechender Rechtsprechung zu versehen, mal Gesetz,
zu beschließen, was die Korruption auch mal konkret verbietet. Stattdessen halt immer so diese ganze Eierei und kein Lobbyverzeichnis und was nicht alles und dann kommen solche Sachen raus,
da wundert man sich dann irgendwie auch echt über nichts mehr.
Was sie unterschreiben müssen ist, in den Jahren zwanzig einundzwanzig. Ist schon mal das Jahr eingegrenzt. Habe ich keine finanziellen Leistungen?
Begrenzung auf finanziell. Weder direkt noch über Gesellschaften
aus dem Kauf oder Verkauf von Medizinprodukten wie etwa Schutzausstattung, Test- und Impfbedarf, aus dem Vermitteln von Kontakt
aus der Weiterleitung von Angeboten oder Anfragen oder aus der Unterstützung oder Beratung dritter bei solchen Tätigkeiten im Zusammenhang mit der Bekämpfung der Covid-Neunzehn-Pandemie,
erhalten. Das müssen sie unterschreiben. Sonstige Korruption ist kein Problem.
Ist alles gut.
Ja. Okay, man sieht, denn klingt ab meiner auch.
Permanent Spaß, sich darüber äh aufzuregen. Aber es ist ja schön, dass wir so unseren unseren Rage trichter haben, irgendwie ab und zu mal so ein Twitterset, dann geht's einem auch gleich viel besser.
Ja ein warmer Hafermilch mit Honig und dann.
Wird nicht immer allen gerecht dabei, aber es ist muss einfach Verständnis dafür haben. Ab und zu. Ich mache das auch gar nicht so oft.
Aber wenn, dann macht's auch richtig Spaß.
Es ist wirklich.
Leute, ich glaube, wir entlassen euch jetzt mal hier ähm mit dem Corona-Thema für heute. Denkt mal drüber nach.
Euch noch schnell einen Infoausweis aus.
Genau und dann läuft das auch mit den Festivals. Könnt ihr auch zu hier ist.
Die sieben große Festivals Deutschland, Schweiz haben heute abgesagt, ne? Hurricane und wer nicht alles.
Einfach keine Rechtssicherheit so, ne, also für die ganz großen Dinger ist auf jeden Fall keine Perspektive. Für kleinere Sachen muss man mal gucken. Da ist vielleicht noch was zu retten.
Gott, ey, jetzt klicke ich hier das Browserfenster zu und habe noch diese Seite auf, ne.
Und bist du positiv.
Schreiben sie dahin ist.
Brauche ich doch gar nicht zu Ende zu lesen, wo ich schon weiß, das ist nicht das, was ihr gebaut.
Auf einer SIM Card.
Nein, bestimmt nicht.
Ja. Ich sage euch, startet mal einen richtigen Bitcoin klein und ladet euch mal die Blockchain runter,
Viel Spaß. Oh Gott, genug geratet, Leute. Wir sagen jetzt äh tschüss.
Ach so, nee, warte, wollen wir nochmal so eine, jetzt haben wir ja ähm.
Was Sebastian jetzt noch.
Mich auch noch gefragt heute, ich habe mit Thomas gesprochen. Der hat Bock auf äh Clubhaus am Montag.
Könnten dann, ne? Wir haben ja irgendwie also was wir jetzt gerade noch auch ganz ein bisschen außen vor gelassen haben, was auch nochmal wirklich ein Thema wird, diese gesamten Konzepte,
Impfausweis, auch übrigens das, worüber wir hier gerade gesprochen haben, mit den fünf Blockchains die sind ja auch für Test.
Ne? Also die sollen nicht nur Impfstatus registrieren können, sondern auch Teststatus.
Ne, was wo ich mir noch keine abschließende Meinung zugebildet habe, weil das ja potenziell,
Der Weg wäre aus der Diskriminierung heraus, zu sagen, alles klar, es gibt kostenlose Tests, die die geimpft sind, brauchen keinen Test, die die nicht geimpft sind, kommen mit einem Test rein. Ne?
Da würden wir ja langsam in Bereich kommen, der in Ordnung wäre,
und das habe ich aber noch nicht zu Ende gedacht, deswegen habe ich das heute erstmal in der Sendung ausgeklammert und äh Thomas denkt da auch schon fleißig drauf rum und ich auch und äh Thomas hat würde sich freuen, wenn wir am Montag so eine Clubhausrunde machen.
Dann machen wir das doch einfach.
Ja, sollen wir das machen?
Machen wir das. Einundzwanzig Uhr.
Und,
Lösung naht. Es gibt ja jetzt, habe ich schon mal gesehen, eine äh Clubhausalternative, die auch auf Android läuft. Die habe ich hier auf meinem Android-Handy schon installiert. Habe ich ja auch, kriege ich ja auch immer bitteres Feedback, ich würde kein Android benutzen
das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Ich habe hier ein Indoor-Handy liegen. Nokia, Android Handy
Und auf dem habe ich eine App namens, die aber leider bisher noch im Invide-Modus ist und noch nicht so ganz fertig, aber sobald das möglich ist, denke ich, werden wir der dann eine Chance geben.
Ja, ich habe das auch schon länger im Test und ähm da ist noch Arbeit zu leisten,
Meanwhile und Clubhaus könnt ihr auf jeden Fall auch die Meterebene als Club dort finden. Da werden dann diese Veranstaltungen auch äh eingereiht sein, so dass ihr da nix äh verpasst. Ist ja sehr einfach, was zu verpassen.
Montag einundzwanzig Uhr, sagen wir, ne?
Montag, fünfzehnter März, einundzwanzig Uhr.
Genau. Und dann.
Thomas, Tim und Linus und allen anderen, die sich daran beteiligen möchten.
Okay.
Dann bis bald, tschüss.
Ciao, ciao.